Und damit Herzlich Willkommen zu jedem letzten Donnerstag in einem ungeradenen Monat. Hier auf Fritz ist das Chaos Radio. Implomun, das heißt da sind Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, die das Studio stürmen und dafür sorgen, dass wir etwas über Technik lernen, die uns so im allgemeinen Leben umgibt. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich versuche das Ganze so zu bändigen und zu erklären, dass möglicherweise auch ihr was davon habt und ich heiße Herzlich Willkommen Erdgeist vom Chaos Computer Club. Danimo vom Chaos Computer Club.
Einen schönen guten Abend.
Und Henrik vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo. Und das Thema, das wir heute besprochen haben, das dürfte den ein oder anderen von uns, nee eigentlich alle in irgendeiner Form schon mal erreicht haben. Also vielleicht nicht unbedingt negativ, weil man vorher dafür gesorgt hat, dass es einen gar nicht erreichen kann. Aber ich glaube, ihr alle habt euch schon mal damit beschäftigt oder beschäftigen müssen. Wir wollen heute nämlich über Online-Werbung sprechen. Und ich möchte das gerne anfangen mit einer kleinen Geschichte, die ich neulich erlebt habe. Aber bevor ich das mache, möchte ich die anwesenden Herren mal fragen. Erdgeist, hast du schon mal negative Erfahrungen mit Online-Werbung gehabt im Browser, dass dir irgendwas untergeschoben wurde oder sowas? Oder dass du was gesehen hast, wo du dachtest, nee, das will ich lieber nicht?
Ständig, aber ich klick halt nicht drauf. Meine Mama hat mir gesagt, nix draufklicken.
Aber du siehst die, also du hast keinen Adblocker.
Och, du greifst da schon wieder vor, aber ich hab auch mehrere Adblocker installiert. Schalte die ab und zu mal aus, weil man muss ja so ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie der Rest der Welt so das Internet sieht. Man kann sonst einfach die Größe dieses Problems einfach nicht begreifen, wenn man nicht ab und zu mal das ungefilterte Internet auf sich wirken lässt.
Dann schaltest du ihn aber schnell wieder an. Verstehe.
Ja, nach den Spamfiltern bleibt Gott sei Dank, äh, nach den Adfiltern. Aber auch Spamfiltern bleibt Gott sei Dank nicht mehr ganz so viel übrig.
Verstehe. Und Henrik?
Also ich sehe, glaube ich, sehr wenig Werbung. Jedenfalls habe ich immer das Gefühl.
Okay, ich hatte neulich, trieb ich mich auf meinem Smartphone herum und habe auf einer, das finde ich schon mal sehr interessant, das wird auch sozusagen heute ein Punkt, auf einer sehr vertrauenswürdigen Seite rumgesurft. Ich glaube, es war der Guardian oder so was. Also es war eine englischsprachige, eher seriöse Nachrichtenseite auf jeden Fall. Und sie hatten ganz unten, man kennt das, vielleicht hat das gesehen, gibt es so Werbungen, die sieht aus wie, du hast diesen Artikel gelesen, vielleicht gefallen dir auch diese Artikel. Und dann ist dann immer so zwei Reihen von Boulevardesgästen, schlimmen Dingen, die einem angeboten werden. Sie, diese Hollywoodstars aus den 80ern, die heute ganz schlimm aussehen oder... Genau, Clickbait. Diese Schönheitsoperationen sind total krass in die Hose gegangen und so was. Und da war halt einer von diesen Artikeln und ja, ich gebe es zu. Ich wollte wissen, wie dieser eine Fernsehstar, den ich früher total super fand, heute aussieht.
Als?
Nee, Mr. T. Und habe halt drauf geklickt und kam auf so eine Gossip-Seite, auf so eine Boulevardesgaseite. Und da ging dann sofort also die Seite auf und dann aber so ein Bildschirm, also so eine Grafik kam. Ja, wenn sie diese Inhalte sehen wollen, dann müssten sie jetzt hier also am besten dieses Abo abschließen, weil dann können sie dieses Video sehen. Nicht von Abo, Schallengeis. Aber nur so, wenn sie das Video sehen wollen, dann klicken sie mal bitte hier und so. Das sieht mir schon sehr, sehr seltsam nach so einer, na ja, nach so einem schmierigen Ding aus. Und dann hab ich sozusagen, dann gibt es ja immer diese Zubuttons. Also so ein X, wo man draufklickt und dann soll angeblich die Grafik zunehmen. Ich dachte so, ich habe aber schon auch erlebt, so wenn man da draufklickt, dann ist das gar nicht der Zubuttons, sondern passiert was anderes. Ich bin total clever. Ich drücke jetzt einfach im Browser zurück. Gehe auf die vorige Seite. Weit gefehlt. Es wurde sofort eine Art Abo abgeschlossen oder versucht abzuschließen, wie das genau funktioniert. Klären wir nachher noch. Und das hat, das einzige, was mich sozusagen gerettet hat, ist, dass mein Mobilfunkbetreiber noch mal so eine Vorschaltseite gemacht hat vor dieser, vor dieses Abo-Ding. Und deswegen bin ich sozusagen dem noch im letzten Moment von der Schippe gesprungen. Und das ist sozusagen mein schönstes Online-Werbungserlebnis. Und wir wollen heute darüber sprechen, wie diese ganze Industrie eigentlich funktioniert, was da technisch dahinter steckt, aber auch wie die Geldflüsse sind, warum das eigentlich so viel ist, was da alles in eurem Browser passiert. All das wollen wir heute Abend hier klären. Und ich denke auch, dass ich möglicherweise nicht der Einzige bin, der so eine Geschichte hat. Vielleicht mögt ihr eure auch mit uns teilen heute. 0331 70 97 110 wäre die Nummer dafür, wenn ihr so eine richtig schöne Online-Werbungsgeschichte habt, die euch vielleicht mal passiert ist. Muss nicht schlimm ausgegangen sein, unterhaltsam reicht. 0331 70 97 110. So, wir fangen aber hier jetzt ganz von vorne an mit der Online-Werbung. Wie ist es denn dazu eigentlich gekommen? Also ich meine, es war ja nicht immer so, dass Webseiten mit bunten Dingern, die automatisch Musik abspielen und Abos abschließen, verseucht waren. Das fing ja wahrscheinlich alles viel langsamer an.
Na ganz am Anfang war das Internet so ein Zusammenschluss von vielen Computern an Universitäten, von so Wissenschaftlern, die da ihre Forschungsergebnisse ausgetauscht haben. Es gibt Behauptungen, es wäre vom Militär aufgebautes, ausfallsicheres Kommunikationssystem gewesen. Aber da wäre man auch nicht auf die Idee gekommen, diese Leute da jetzt mit Werbung in großem Skill zuzuballern. Aber im Jahr 1993 hat das erste Mal, als es noch so E-Mail nicht so richtig gab, eine Firma aus den USA namens DEC angefangen, Ersatzteile für Computer zu bewerben in Newsgroups, im Newsnet. Und das war so die allererste, was man so als Werbung bezeichnen könnte, wo das Internet seine Unschuld verloren hat.
Also wohl ein Einzelhändler jetzt nicht, die Firma DEC selber, so wie ich das verstanden habe.
Was ist da passiert? Der hat was gemacht? Wie sah die Werbung damals aus?
War eine Preisliste.
Also der hat einfach in einem Forum quasi eine Preisliste gepostet?
Ja, auch an mehrere Foren. Das war so das erste Mal und dann zwei Jahre später hat sich so ein Ehepaar, beide Anwälte, haben gedacht, das kann ja nicht sein, dass diese langhaarigen Hippies da einmal so eine Kommerzfreie Zone aufmachen. Das kann ja nicht angehen und haben dann eine Green Card Lottery, die man wahrscheinlich immer noch sieht, wenn man dieses E-Mail-Medium noch benutzt. Die haben so eine Green Card Lotterie beworben.
Kurz erklären, was ist eine Green Card?
Eine Green Card ist so eine Aufenthaltsberechtigung in den Vereinigten Staaten, mit denen man arbeiten und Geld verdienen kann. Also sprich, wenn man da Bürger werden möchte in den USA, dann braucht man so eine Green Card und die wird damit, jeder und sein Hund dort auch diesen amerikanischen Traum wirklich verfolgen kann, werden die ausgewürfelt und ausgelost.
Also die Verlosung gibt es aber tatsächlich?
Die Verlosung gibt es tatsächlich. Gerüchteweise auch im Freundeskreis hat es mal jemanden erwischt, der da hin wollte. Auf jeden Fall hatte dann dieses Ehepaar sich einen Pearl Programmierer, also Pearl ist eine Programmiersprache, die damals noch ganz hipp im Internet gewesen ist, hat sich geholt und dann gegen der üblichen Etikette, die man so im Internet normalerweise befolgt hat, dass man so, wenn man in diversen Newsgroups gelesen hat, wie kann man das heute vergleichen, so Foren, statt irgendwie einmal diese Nachricht irgendwo hin zu posten und dafür zu sorgen, dass das System diesen Nachricht, dass man dies nur einmal sehen muss, haben die wirklich alle Newsgroupforen damit vollgespammt und haben dann, war auch ganz stolz, haben gesagt, die haben wie 100.000 Dollar Umsatz dadurch erzeugt und hat sich nur ein paar Cent gekostet, diesen Programmierer da anzustellen und die sind dann irgendwie zum echten Hassobjekt des damals noch sehr jungen Internets geworden, aber haben es dann auch nicht bereut und später noch ein Buch darüber geschrieben, wie man das Internet für Werbung benutzen kann?
So war das früher, wie ist es heute? Was für Werbeformen reden wir heute und was für Werbeformen gibt es eigentlich alles?
Ja, also das, was die meisten wahrscheinlich kennen mittlerweile, ist gar nicht mehr so sehr das, was auf dem PC ist. Viele konsumieren das Internet wahrscheinlich heute eher über Handys. Da ist es halt beliebt so fast ganz formatige Anzeigen über das, was man eigentlich sehen will, zu legen. Die etwas weniger auffällige Variante sind nervige blinkende Dinger, die an den Seiten von eher Desktop-Rechnern auftauchen und irgendetwas bewerben. Und das sind so die Sachen, die bei mir eigentlich gar nicht mehr auftauchen, weil ich sie schlicht und ergreifend wegblockiere. Die ganz schlimmen Sachen sind dann so fast seitenfüllend, beziehungsweise wenn man aus Versehen über die mit der Maus drübergeht, dann füllen sie die ganze Seite und spielen Sounds ab. Das ist aber eher ein Trend der Neuzeit. So wirklich diese Banner-Einblendung, die gibt es fast seit ich das Internet benutze. Also schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange.
Und darüber reden wir heute auch, über die Form, wo auf Webseiten, also jetzt egal ob mobil oder auf dem Desktop sozusagen Werbung eingeblendet wird.
Ja, es gibt noch weitere Formen. Das ganze Artikel eigentlich oder das Werbung als Artikel getarnt auf dem Telefon erscheint. Das heißt, dass dort die Formatgrenzen innerhalb des Journalismus inzwischen so gesprengt werden, dass man nicht mal mehr markiert, dass es sich um eine Anzeige handelt. Dass einzelne Stichworte innerhalb der Artikel, die dort veröffentlicht werden, so markiert werden, dass man da draufklicken soll, um dann sich, wenn es irgendeinen Text um keine Ahnung, eine Waschmaschine gibt, dass man dann plötzlich auf Amazon weitergeleitet wird und dort sich Waschmaschinen kaufen soll. Und das ist dann schon die Art Werbung, die man trotz Werbeblocker auch noch mitbekommt. Das heißt, wenn dann die Grenze zwischen Inhalt und Werbung verschwindet, darüber reden wir nicht so doll, heute dann hat man schon das Problem, dass man immer noch Ziel von Online-Werbung ist.
Okay, wir reden heute über die Formen, die man technisch analysieren kann, die auch technisch spannend ist, weil da verschiedene Leute mit einer Rolle spielen. Wie ist denn das überhaupt mit dem Geld, also das Problem, könnte man ja sagen, oder dieser Wirtschaftszweig, sagen die anderen, hat ja eine gewisse Relevanz und eine gewisse Größe. Das heißt, der Verdacht liegt nahe, da wird tatsächlich auch verdient. In relevanten Größen. Habt ihr da Zahlen?
Ja, wir haben Zahlen, aber die sind auch immer so ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen, weil das ja so ein großes, ein großes, naja, wenn man Werbung irgendwo einblendet, dann muss man nicht immer mit Geld bezahlen, sondern auch durch das Linktausch zum Beispiel. Da kann man sagen, da wäre angeblich Geld geflossen, aber in Wirklichkeit hat man dort einfach nur einen Banner Werbung beim anderen geschaltet. Kann ich dir nachher erklären, du greifst ja immer immer ordentlich vor, aber angeblich sind wir so in der Größenordnung von 40 Milliarden US-Dollar für den US-Werbemarkt. Für den Deutschen sind die Zahlen lustigerweise andersrum. Da wird eher gesagt, dass es durch die Adblocker sowas wie Schäden von 14 Milliarden Euro in Deutschland passieren. Das sind so sehr, sehr verschieden große Größenordnung. Deswegen ist es echt schwer einzuschätzen. Da der Werbemarkt ja auch befeuert ist von... Normalerweise hat man ja so ein System, dass ein Kunde geht irgendwo einkaufen und der Händler gibt Teile des Gewinns dafür aus, um wieder Werbung zu machen, damit er mehr Kunden bekommt. So funktioniert normalerweise klassisch Werbung. Die BWLer da draußen an den Telefonen, äh, an den Radios werden mich da nicht köpfen für, weil wir ja auch Brennpflege und sowas als Werbung machen. Aber eigentlich muss das Geld irgendwo herkommen und das meistens Leute, die Handel betreiben und dort Teile des Umsatzes oder der Einnahmen wieder abgeben in Richtung Werbung. Und das ist aber deutlich weniger Geld, als dann am Ende zum Beispiel bei Google und Facebook grad hängen bleiben. Und das liegt daran, dass noch ziemlich viel Geld in dieses System reingepumpt wird, weil die Leute hoffen, dass dann irgendwann mal mit dem Werbemarkt Geld gemacht wird. Das ist so, hm.
Also quasi was heutzutage in Werbung investiert wird, ist noch viel mehr als messbares Ergebnis zumindest hinten rauskommt, weil die Leute einfach hoffen, dass es was bringt?
Nee, es glauben Leute, dass diese Werbefirmen irgendwann mal noch deutlich mehr Geld machen und pumpen da schon mal Geld in Form von Venture Capital in diese Werbefirmen, aber auch in Firmen, die nicht wirklich was herstellen und verkaufen, wie so Online-Plattformen, die vielleicht irgendwann später mal Geld machen. Und das ist alles nicht wirklich aus Umsatz generiertes Geld.
Aber woher kommt das ganze Geld?
Na, Venture Capital ziemlich viel.
Also Venture Capital, da sagen Leute, haben viel Geld und pumpen das irgendwo rein. Aber woher haben die das Geld?
Na, von Leuten, die glauben, man könnte spielend mal 10% ROI machen. Also sprich, man kann ganz...
Return on investment.
Na ja, und aus vorherigen Venture Capital-Anlagen.
Einige Firmen funktionieren ja auch.
Das klingt mir sehr nach einem Seifenblasending.
Ja, ich finanziere 100 Firmen, eine wird ganz groß und die 99, die dann zugrunde gehen, die habe ich damit dann auch wegfinanziert. Das ist so die Hoffnung.
Also das heißt, man finanziert 99 Firmen, die in Online-Werbung machen und eine, die was produziert?
Eher anders. Im Werbemarkt sind ein paar Firmen, naja nicht nur ein paar, inzwischen viele Firmen und viele von denen werden nichts werden. Aber genug Leute glauben, dass in Online-Werbung Geld steckt. Und ja, da wird Geld reingepumpt. Und außerdem sind viele Firmen, die Online-Werbung schalten, ja auch nicht wirklich Firmen, die schon ernstzunehmend Umsatz machen, sondern auch dort ist Venture-Kapital drin. Wo sie dann hoffen, dass irgendwie jetzt Liefer-irgendwas-Dienst mal später was wird. Und im Vorfeld muss viel Werbung geschaltet werden. Und auch dort kommt dann aus dem Venture-Kapital, was am Ende auch wieder Leute sind.
Also ich muss sagen, ich verstehe immer noch nicht genau, wo das Geld herkommt. Aber ich verstehe, es wird viel Geld in Werbung investiert, obwohl man noch gar nicht so genau weiß, was der Effekt ist. Wir machen damit gleich weiter. Ich habe ja auch aufgerufen, anzurufen, falls ihr eine schöne Werbungsgeschichte habt. Bernd hat angerufen aus Pankow. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo Markus, hallo der Rest der Runde.
Hallo, was ist dein schönstes Werbeerlebnis, online Werbeerlebnis?
Na ich hatte das mal gehabt, da habe ich abends an meinem PC gesessen und hatte im Internet gesurft. Ich weiß noch nicht mal genau, welche Seite das war.
Mit oder ohne Werbeblocker?
Ohne Werbeblocker. Und auf einmal habe ich komische Geräusche gehört. Also so Klopfen und Rascheln und sowas. Ich habe nichts gesehen auf der Webseite, ja. Und dann bin ich wirklich fast durch die ganze Wohnung getigert, um zu gucken, wo denn diese Geräusche herkommen. Bis ich dann festgestellt habe, die kam aus meinem Lautsprecher. Da waren unten auf der Webseite, da war ich noch nicht mal, das war ziemlich weit unten, da hätte ich noch scrollen müssen, irgendeine, ich glaube, das war eine Filmwerbung oder sowas. So ein Video, so ein eingebettetes Video. Und das hat mich wirklich irgendwie, naja, so ungefähr drei Minuten richtig beschäftigt. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, welcher Film es war. Ich weiß, dass ich ihn bestimmt nicht gesehen habe danach. Das nervt ja total ab.
Das ist aber auch das Schlimmste, was einem passieren kann, dass man auf eine Webseite kommt und wird dann direkt erst mal mit irgendwelchem Audiokram voll genervt. Das hat dann die Browser-Hersteller erst mal dazu getrieben, überhaupt so ein Sound-Icon anzuzeigen für Seiten, die Krach machen. Und viele Werbungen sind doch erst mal per Default mute, also spielen keinen Sound ab. Und sobald man dann mit der Maus drüber geht oder extra so ein Icon anklickt, dann wird zu dem Film quasi der Sound abgespielt. Aber schlimm ist eigentlich schon, dass da überhaupt irgendwas flitzt und animiert, weil das nimmt meine Aufmerksamkeit komplett vom Rest der anderen Seite weg.
Das ist natürlich der Zweck der Werbung, logisch. Die will ja deine Aufmerksamkeit haben.
Aber in dem Fall hast du ja noch nicht mal gewusst, worum es geht. Und das ist natürlich dann die ganz große Gefahr. Wenn es dich quasi oben vom Banner schon anschreit, dann wärs ja noch gut gewesen.
Das ist ja wirklich total absurd. Hast du denn seitdem eine Software entzelt, die sowas unterbindet?
Auf dem PC habe ich keinen Adblocker. Aber da surf ich auch wenig. Auf dem iPad habe ich einen Adblocker. Deshalb kann ich auch Bildtee nicht mehr ansurfen. Total traurig.
Das ist natürlich sehr schade.
Ist total schade. Und damit bin ich auch zufrieden. Obwohl der auch nicht alles wegblockt, habe ich irgendwie gemerkt. Irgendwas schleicht sich da immer durch.
Über die Technik des Adblockings und warum, reden wir im Verlauf der Sendung noch. Da kannst du noch schön dranbleiben.
Und auch über Adblock Plus und den neuen Deal.
Wir möchten das zumindest mal thematisieren. Das kommt alles noch auf die Sendung. Bernd, aber dir erstmal vielen Dank für die Geschichte. Und viel Glück und vielleicht doch noch einen Adblocker auf dem PC installieren. Ich weiß ja nicht, könnte eine gute Idee sein. Bis dann, tschüss. So, und dann haben wir noch den Justus22 aus Treptow.
Hallo.
Ja, hi, grüß euch.
Und was ist deine schönste Werbegeschichte?
Ja, ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Also ich glaube, dass diese ganzen Systeme noch nicht so mächtig und ausgereift sind, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Folgendes Beispiel, ich musste neulich für meine kleine Schwester nach Norwegen googeln und klicke auf die Wikipedia-Seite. Und während ich so über die Seite schweife, wollte ich mir doch noch mal den neuen BMW von meinem Onkel angucken. Und dann kriege ich Werbung von der Norwegenreise. Also rechts am Google-Rand. Aber also 10 Stück, obwohl ich da gar nicht hinfahren will. Also irgendwie scheint diese Einordnung teilweise noch gar nicht so richtig zu funktionieren. Oder ich werde einfach irgendwie, irgendwie wird mir was Falsches zugetraut. Also irgendwie ist das noch nicht ganz so ausgereift. Habe ich den Eindruck zumindest.
Naja, aber du hattest schon was mit Norwegen zu tun.
Aber da hätte man mir ein anderes Angebot machen müssen. Also weiß ich nicht, irgendwie Norwegen allgemeine Infos oder sowas.
Ja, klären wir heute auch noch, wie das zustande kommt, wenn man Dinge gesehen hat und dann werden die dann plötzlich angeboten. Ich habe tatsächlich mal ein Geburtstagsgeschenk auf einer von diesen hier ich bastel selber einen Verkaufsland-Plattformen gegoogelt und bin dann weitergesurft, dann ist mir exakt dieses Produkt auch angeboten worden. Also vielleicht könnt ihr das nachher auch noch erklären. Hast du dich denn seitdem mit mehr Werbeblockern ausgestattet oder surfst du trotzdem noch weiter ohne?
Ich hatte bis vor Kurzem noch einen, aber mittlerweile mache ich die Werbung einfach stumm und lasse sie durchlaufen. Das ist auch sehr zum Kotzen, wenn man dann auch mal auf eine Seite kommt, wo man wirklich was angucken will, was einen interessiert, dann kommt dieser Werbeblocker und dann weisen sie dich ja schon darauf hin, wenn du unsere Inhalte konsumieren möchtest, dann bestell bitte dieses Ding aus und da beug ich mich dann dem System.
Also es gibt ja Seiten, wo man das natürlich nicht mal lesen kann, aber die meisten Seiten belassen es ja bei einem Hinweis. Also dass sie sagen, hier wir zeigen es dir, aber mach es bitte aus. Ist das dann so, dass du sagst, okay, ich mach das, weil ich will, dass ihr mit Werbung Geld verdient oder?
Also an mir verdienen sie damit kein Geld, weil ich davon nichts kaufe, was mir da zugespielt wird. Also wenn da irgendwie eine Werbung für Katzen tut, dann interessiert mich das nicht. Und deswegen mach ich die Werbung per se auf stumm, weil da war noch nie irgendwas dabei, was mich interessiert hat. Also wirklich. Also wenn die mir eine Werbung für einen richtig guten Tee machen würden, dann würde ich drauf einfallen.
Wie war nochmal dein Name und deine email-Adresse?
Also liebe Werbetreibende, wir können jetzt schon mal sagen, wenn ihr männliche so ungefähr 22 Jahre in Treptoköpenick mit Tee anvisieren würdet, dann könnt ihr vielleicht ein bisschen Umsatz machen. Aber das ist eine interessante Frage, was wir heute auch noch klären können, ist nämlich dieses, wann verdienen denn eigentlich die Leute, die die Werbung bei sich schalten lassen Geld? Also sagen, ich bin eine Seite und verkaufe irgendwie Werbeplatz, verdiene ich dann nur Geld, wenn du sozusagen als User da was kauft? Oder ist das auch irgendwie anders? Das können wir jetzt jetzt auch noch fragen.
Ja genau, da scheint das irgendwie nicht zu funktionieren, weil ich gehe auch manchmal auf Messmer und gucke mir eine geile Sorte an, wo ich dann denke, egal, die will ich eigentlich haben. Und da kriege ich dann keine Werbung. Und da frage ich mich dann, falle ich total durchs Raster?
Und bin ich der Einzige?
Deswegen lohnt sich das einfach nicht, mir da irgendwie ein Profil zu erstellen. Okay, der kauft Tee, dann kauft er auch das. Und wenn er Tee kauft, dann kauft er in der Regel auch das und das. Weiß ich nicht, ob ich da irgendwie durchs Raster falle. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Hättest du das gerne? Hättest du gerne, dass die Werbung so gut ist, dass du geile Angebote bekommst? Also bei mir ist es immer so ein Zwiespalt, weil gerade auf so großen Einkaufsplattformen kauft man was und dann kriegt man irgendwie 1000 Angebote und denkt so, es ist alles Quatsch, aber ich fände es eigentlich nicht schlecht, wenn er mir irgendwas empfiehlt, was mich tatsächlich interessieren könnte.
Das sind so Produktinformationen und wenn du dann eh schon das eingeblendet bekommst und nichts dagegen tun kannst, dann könnte es ja wenigstens relevant mal für dich sein. Ich kann den Gedanken ganz schön nachvollziehen.
Also ich finde, wenn die mir wirklich Sachen schicken würden, wo ich noch nicht selber drauf gekommen bin, wo ich sage, hey, das klingt doch ganz geil, das könnte ich ja mal ausprobieren, dann würde ich sagen, das wäre dann eine geile Sache. Aber ich meine so, ich glaube dann scheint es bestimmte Muster zu geben, durch die ich einfach nicht reinpasse. Also irgendwie scheint mein Profil, meine Kaufkraft, irgendwie woanders zu liegen.
Du bist zu kompliziert fürs Internet.
Wahrscheinlich.
Okay, Justus, dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. Also finde ich es sehr interessant, dass Menschen, die hier anrufen, keine Werbeblocker benutzen auf Rechner. Also bei mir ist das nicht umgedreht. Ich habe lange lange auf dem Mobiltelefon keinen Werbeblocker gehabt, sondern nur auf dem Rechner.
Und auf Mobiltelefonen ist es zumindest auf Android gefühlt schwieriger, eine vernünftige Balance zwischen sicherem Browser und Adblocker zu bekommen, als auf einem normalen Rechner.
Inwiefern?
Also ich wüsste zum Beispiel nicht, dass es für Chrome auf dem mobilen Endgerät vernünftige Adblocker gibt, aber das mag auch an mir liegen.
Achso, das ist natürlich interessant, weil du den Browser von einer Firma benutzt, die Haupteinnahmequelle Werbung ist.
Exakt. Und einfach, naja, das ist ja auf dem Desktop auch so, aber da haben sie halt Plugins. Und auf der mobilen Variante gibt es halt keine Plugins.
Also die große Adblocker-Studie behauptet, dass 24, 7% der Nutzer Adblocker installiert haben. Das heißt, dass wir hier gerade dann so ein paar Outlay, also ein paar sehr, die Zuschauer am Chaosradio haben das nicht installiert, obwohl 25% der User da draußen Adblocker installiert haben. Da haben wir aber gerade echt Glück gehabt mit den Anrufern.
Wieso? 75% haben keine Adblocker installiert? Das ist doch sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie anrufen.
Ja, aber doch nicht bei dem technisch versierten Publikum, was wir im Chaosradio normalerweise haben.
Du hast da, glaube ich, was missverstanden, Herr Erdgeist. Weil wir machen das Chaosradio genau für die Leute, die sich nicht auskennen und vielleicht noch etwas dazulernen müssen. Und das machen wir auch gleich weiter. Nachdem wir aber die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr gemacht haben, sind wir wieder da.
Diesmal in der Fritz-Radio-Show mit Kraftclub.
Hallo Fritz, wir sind wieder. Stefan Israeh, Felix Brummer, Radio mit K. Die aktuelle Folge zum Thema Rausch hat an der Grenze zum Verbotenwerden. Wir bewegen uns auf der Rasierklinge des Rotstiftes vom Rundfunkrat in der aktuellen Sendung Radio mit K zum Thema Rausch. Schaltet ein.
Radio mit K, die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Kraftclub.
Diesen Samstag ab 20 Uhr bei Fritz im Radio. Und schon ab morgen Abend 18 Uhr bei Fritz im Netz.
Fritz.de slash Radio mit K.
Radio mit K, die Show mit Steffen und Felix von Kraftclub. Ob im Radio oder im Netz. Auf jeden Fall bei Fritz.
Um fast genau halb elf. Und sind wir eigentlich mit den Nachrichten schon fertig? Oder brauchen wir noch einen ganz, ganz, ganz kleinen Moment, bevor Timo Maschewski hier im Studio die Nachrichten an uns ganz frisch aus dem Drucker gezogen präsentieren kann? Jetzt geht's los. Fritz Nachrichten mit Timo Maschewski.
Bundespräsident Gauck hat vor einer neuen Ängstlichkeit in Deutschland gewarnt. Angst vor dem Fremden sei zwar nichts Ungewöhnliches, sagte er beim Katholikentag in Leipzig. Die Erfahrung habe aber gezeigt, dass die Ängste oft unbegründet seien. Leider werde die Angst in Deutschland auch von Leuten ausgenutzt, um Hysterie zu verbreiten. Als Beispiel nennt Gauck die Pegida-Demonstrationen in Sachsen, bei denen gegen Islamisierung protestiert wird, obwohl es in Sachsen kaum Muslime gibt. Die Europäische Union will das Mittelmeer in Zukunft mit Drohnen überwachen lassen. Die Bildzeitung berichtet unter Berufung auf die Bundesregierung, dass dafür insgesamt 67 Millionen Euro ausgegeben werden sollen. Die Drohnen sollen im Mittelmeer kleine Schlauchboote aufspüren, mit denen Flüchtlinge versuchen, nach Europa zu kommen. Die Linkspartei hat die Pläne kritisiert. Sie sagt, damit schotte sich die EU weiter ab. Internetanbieter sollen in Zukunft Strafe zahlen, wenn die Internetverbindung nicht so schnell ist wie beworben. Das fordern die Grünen. Laut Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung wollen sie im Bundestag in den nächsten Tagen einen Antrag einbringen. Darin wird gefordert, dass die Internetgeschwindigkeit mindestens 90 Prozent der angegebenen Maximalgeschwindigkeit erreichen muss. Wenn der Wert unterschritten wird, sollen die Kunden Schadensersatz fordern können. In den jetzigen Verträgen sehen die Grünen eine Mogelpackung, weil darin nur angegeben ist, wie hoch die Geschwindigkeit maximal sein kann.
Das Wetter.
Die Temperaturen in Berlin und Brandenburg liegen im Moment zwischen 12 und 15 Grad. Am Himmel gibt es hier und da einige Wolken. Im Laufe der nächsten Stunden klart der Himmel aber auch noch weiter auf. Regen ist erst mal nicht in Sicht. Im Laufe des Tages ziehen dann neue Wolken rein. Die können später auch Regen oder Gewitter mit sich bringen. Das Ganze bereits 20 bis 23 Grad. Im Moment fließt der Verkehr auf den Straßen. So weit gut, es liegen uns keine aktuellen Meldungen vor. Allen unterwegs eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Heute Chaosradio Imble Moon, mein Name ist Markus Richter und zu Gast sind Gäste aus dem Chaos Computer Club, nämlich Erdgeiss, Danimo und Henrik. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und gleich sprechen wir noch mit jemanden, der in der Online-Werbebranche zu tun hatte.
Ein Aussteiger.
Ein Aussteiger. Und vorher wollen wir aber noch kurz sagen, worum es geht, nämlich Online-Werbung. Habt ihr vielleicht schon festgestellt. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon ein bisschen sozusagen den groben Rahmen besprochen, also wo das Ganze herkommt, wie es anfing und wie es jetzt mittlerweile aussieht und ich habe auch eine kleine Geschichte erzählt, wie ich fast mal auf eine Abo-Falle reingefallen wäre.
Sag mal, hast du eigentlich schon mal selber Werbung geschaltet?
Ich habe selber auch schon mal Werbung geschaltet. Das war tatsächlich sehr lustig. Ich habe, es gibt ja das Radiorollenspiel, also was hier sozusagen als Hörspiel Blumen bei Fritz auch schon gelaufen ist und das haben wir mal in der Freien Wildbahn betrieben und da habe ich bei einem anderen Webradiosendung einen Banner geschaltet. Das war also so ein Experiment. Wir wollen das mal ausprobieren, mit Facebook-Werbung irgendwie experimentiert und wir wollen jetzt mal so einen Banner für eine Woche, glaube ich, oder so haben wir das geschaltet. Und das war ganz interessant, weil wir haben das, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die Kondition da genommen ist. Ich glaube, das war so, wir zeigen das Banner so und so lange oder bis so und so viele Views irgendwie zusammengekommen sind und dann hat man halt für diese Zeit irgendwie Geld bezahlt. Das ist, glaube ich, das Banner ist kein einziges Mal geklickt worden. Also habe ich den Statistiken meines Webservers zumindest nicht gesehen. Ja, war eine interessante Erfahrung, wo ich auch so dachte, wir haben mich gefragt, wie funktioniert denn das? Also wir hatten ja eh nichts zu verkaufen sozusagen. Wir wollten ja nur, dass Leute uns zuhören.
Hast du danach denn mal eine Telefonumfrage gemacht, um zu schauen, wie dein Brand Awareness danach war?
Wir haben mit einem sehr niedrigen dreistelligen Beträgen gearbeitet. Also ich rede jetzt hier vom Gesamtwerbebudget. Also da war dann nicht mehr.
Aber im Ernst, auch wenn keiner geklickt hat, konntest du das irgendwie mit vermehrten Besuchen korrelieren, weil natürlich jeder sich gemerkt hat, was auf diesem Banner drauf stand.
Nein. War dein Gesicht auf dem Banner abgebildet? Ah, das war vielleicht das Problem.
Na gut. Wir haben ja vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen. Ich habe versucht, kurz anzusprechen, wie das mit dem Geld ist bei der Werbung. Und der Herr Erdgas hat auch noch etwas vorbereitet.
Ich hatte versucht, dir das zu erklären und war ein wenig ans Stottern gekommen, weil so ein Bild zu beschreiben natürlich immer ein wenig anstrengend. Es gab jemanden, der grob die Zahlen zusammengefasst und nette Diagramme dazu gebastelt hat. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was üblicherweise der Weg ist, hier links zu verbreiten, weil ich will den jetzt nicht vorlesen.
Ja, unter chaosradio.ccc.de gibt es danach der Sendung dann einen ausführlichen Post auch und da gibt es auch Show Notes, die jetzt vielleicht auch automatisch schon erstellt werden. Also nicht automatisch, sondern von Leuten da draußen.
Vielen Dank an dieser Stelle übrigens.
Shownote.es und da wird auf jeden Fall der Link stehen. Aber du kannst dir trotzdem kurz erzählen, was drin steht.
Grob ist das, das Diagramm bei diesem Pfeil, der da so von dem Realgeld, wie viel Geld wirklich aus der Wirtschaft da reinfließt, was nicht so das Spielgeld ist von Banken, dass der Pfeil irgendwie echt deutlich kleiner ist, als das, was am Ende bei Facebook und Google, was die größten Nutznießer der Online-Werbung gerade sind, da rausgeht. Das heißt, dass irgendwo Geld generiert wird, was nicht wirklich aus der Wirtschaft da hinfließt. Und dass es eigentlich nur sich wie ein Pyramidenspiel anfühlt, wenn man das ernsthaft durchrechnet.
Aber was heißt das sagen, ich gebe als jemand, der eine Werbung und einen Auftrag gibt, zahle ich Geldbetrag X, und dann sieht man in dieser Grafik, wie viel davon an dubiose Zwischenhändler abgeschabt wird?
Das sieht man nicht im Einzelnen, aber man sieht einfach, dass die Rechnung nicht aufgeht. Also dass da gerade eine typische Blase, also dass dort Leute auf die Zukunft hoffen und wie Geld reinpumpen, ohne dass dort wirklich Geld aus der Realität kommt.
Ich verstehs immer noch nicht.
Ich geh gleich mal rum mit dem Diagramm und zeig's dir.
Kann jetzt einer von euch erklären? Eine andere Art und Weise?
Auch nicht besser für dich jetzt.
Ich hab noch das Grundproblem noch nicht verstanden. Vielleicht kann uns der Aussteiger weiterhelfen. Hallo und guten Tag. Hallo. Wie dürfen wir dich denn eigentlich nennen? Wie wir wollen. Gut. Hallo. Du hast mal in der Online-Werbebranche gearbeitet.
Genau, ich war mal auf der dunklen Seite der Macht gewesen und habe ganz schlimme Dinge getan im Internet mit Online-Werbung.
Was genau heißt das? Also was genau hast du gearbeitet?
Ich war bei einem großen deutschen App-Server angeschaltet, der dann später von AOL gekauft worden ist und habe international dafür gesorgt, dass Werbung weltweit im Netz verteilt wird nach bestimmten Kriterien und habe dafür gedacht, dass diese Werbeblase immer größer wird und immer bunter und immer kriegbarer und alles ganz eklig ist.
Aber was genau heißt das? Du hast bei einem App-Server gearbeitet. Vielleicht musst du an dieser Stelle mal genauer erklären, wie dieser Weg überhaupt geht. Weil als User sehe ich ja nur, ich komme auf eine Webseite, dort ist Werbung. Eine naive Annahme ist natürlich, okay, Firma X will Werbung schalten, geht also zu der Webseite, auf der ich gerade bin und sagt alter Webseite, schalt mal bitte meine Werbung. Kann man sich vorstellen, vielleicht gibt es noch so einen Zwischenhändler, so jemand, der sagt, ich gestalte dir die Werbung und sage auch welche Webseite Nutzer. Aber ist es so einfach oder wie sieht das System aus?
Es ist nicht so einfach. Also es gibt, nehmen wir jetzt mal an, ich bin ein großer deutscher Verlag mit Boulevard-Zeitungen. Die hat natürlich ganz viele verschiedene Sparten und das Management von den Werbeplätzen, also Artikel unter Sport, das kriegt andere Werbung, Artikel unter Politik zum Beispiel, das ist Mersen aufreiben und ganz harte Arbeit. Man braucht also ausgezügelte Tools, um die Werbung richtig auszusteuern. Das machen App-Server. App-Server steuern vor allem Werbung aus nach bestimmten Kriterien. Und es gibt halt nicht nur einen App-Server-Anbieter, sondern es gibt halt vier, fünf große weltweit. Und dazwischen gibt es noch ganz viele Agenturen, die daran Geld verdienen. Also zum Beispiel hat auch ein großes deutsches Verlagshaus, die verkaufen ihre Welten nicht selbst, sondern sie haben einen Dienstleister, der die Welten anbietet und sich auch eine Marge einstreich dafür. Das heißt, wenn ich Werbung schalte für 30 Euro, kriegt nachher die Webseite aber nur planfest, ist das so zu sagen. 10 Euro bleiben beim Zwischenhändler hängen, dann gehen davon noch Infrastrukturkosten ab für den App-Server, der kostet natürlich auch noch ein bisschen Geld. Und so sinken die Margen nachher mal weiter. Mittlerweile kann man davon ausgehen, dass 60 bis 70 Prozent der Werbekosten, die ich bezahle, um auf der Webseite zu sein, nicht bei der Seite ankommen.
Okay, aber heißt das zu sagen, es ist trotzdem so, dass ich sage, ich möchte auf einer bestimmten Seite Werbung schalten, oder wird das irgendwie anders ausgeliefert?
Das kannst du machen, dann guckst du, wer ist denn der Vermarkter dieser Webseite. Wenn wir einen eigenen haben, dann kommt hier das BD. Dann wird er sagen, klar kannst du machen, wenn du nur auf die Seite willst, kostet extra. Also wenn ich exklusiv auf einer Webseite will, ist das meistens teurer, als wenn ich gleich auf mehreren, gleichgeatmeten Webseiten schalte und dort gleich verteilen lasse. Das ist meistens ein bisschen billiger. Und ja, dafür haben wir natürlich eine Wege gebaut, um das zu machen.
Die dann wie aussieht?
Das ist ein Webfrontend, wo dann die Kampagnenmanager oder die Leute, die Webseiten vermarkten, dann die Werbung einstellen können, sagen können, wann soll sie loslaufen, auf welchen Webseiten jetzt genau soll sie laufen, welche Föderalmittel ist das und was für Kriterien. Männlein, Weiblein, alter Ort. Ich kann also auch z.B. sagen, ich habe hier meine Werbung für Norddeutschland, eine für Süddeutschland, eine für den Rest von Europa. Und dann noch mal eine für die USA. Ich kann Zeit natürlich auch definieren. Ich kann auch definieren. Ich will die Werbung nur an Menschen haben, die vorher auf den Seiten von großen deutschen Automarken waren, damit man dort das Auto bewerben kann. Das kann ich dann alles da einstellen. Und je mehr ich diese Friterien benutze, desto teurer wird die Werbung auch nachher für mich als Kunden.
Aha, das heißt, du sagst, wenn ich hingehe und sage, hier ist Werbung, spiel die bitte irgendwo aus, dann ist das billig. Wenn ich sage, hier ist Werbung, ich möchte, dass alle Leute, die in Treptoköpenick wohnen, ungefähr 22 Jahre männlich sind, justus heißen und gerne Tee trinken sehen wollen, dann wird es teuer.
Genau, dann wird es sogar richtig teuer. Also je klarer definiert, desto teurer wird das.
Aber woher wissen denn die Werbetreibenden überhaupt? Damit ich diese Kriterien ansetze, müssen die ja erst mal wissen, wer ich bin.
Woher kommt das? Naja, deswegen sind bei uns Adserver, wir hatten ja nicht nur eine Webseite, sondern Hunderte, wenn ich da tausende Webseiten...
Also als Adserver heißt es sozusagen, eine Webseite kommt zu euch und sagt, wir haben hier auf unserer Webseite oben und rechts Platz, den vermarktet ihr mal bitte.
Nein, die kommen zu uns und sagen, wir wollen eine Werbung schalten, die wir ordentlich aufsteuern können, bitte macht das mal für uns, dass man die Werbung aufsteuern kann. Dann haben wir da mit den Leuten zusammen gesessen, haben Schulungen gemacht, haben Konzeptearbeit, die man da sinnvollerweise werbungsspezieren könnte. Dann wurde der Code vom Adserver eingebunden in die Webseite, dass man da die Werbung hinkann. Und dann war halt der Code erstmal da, auch wenn keine Werbung drauf war. Und in dem Augenblick hat es angefangen, Cookies zu schreiben für die Leute, die auf die Webseiten draufgegangen sind. Und dadurch konnten wir anfangen, die User zu verfolgen, nachfestbestellen, wo sind die besonders oft auf der Web reiten, was für Themen interessiert diese Person jetzt genau. Und dann wurden die in Gruppen zusammengefasst, dass dann diese Gruppen nachher dann darauf getarget werden kann.
Also das heißt sozusagen, ihr konntet aber nur, also nur in Anführungszeichen, aber sozusagen, ihr habt alle Webseiten überwacht, die bei euch sozusagen sich eingekauft hatten und die euch beauftragt hatten?
Die unsere Infrastruktur benutzt haben, genau. Die haben wir alle mitbekommen.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt, es gibt vier der fünf Firmen in Deutschland, richtig? Große?
Nein, weltweit gibt es vier, fünf Gruppe, die wirklich weltweit tätig sind. In Deutschland reden wir eigentlich von drei bis vier großen Anbietern. Das sind natürlich die Albums, Google ist dabei natürlich, AOL ist dabei und dann noch ein paar, die vor allem in Europa eine Rolle spielen, die ja zwischen Nordamerika eher irrelevant sind.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage, die ich mir als Einzelperson stelle, ist, wenn ich im Internet surfe, wenn ich weiter darauf achte, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich auf eine Seite von einer dieser Firmen treffe? Also quasi, dass ich bei dir lande?
Der, wo ich gearbeitet habe, das waren am meisten ungefähr 40 Prozent gewesen, so zum Bestseiten. Momentan sind die so bei 25 bis 30 Prozent, je nachdem, was die Bestseiten sind. Also schon eine hohe Chance da. Das Spannende ist ja, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr die Bestseite, sondern ich bin jetzt die Person, die die Werbung schalten möchte. Und weil ich ein paar Anoide bin, möchte ich natürlich selbst mitzählen, wie oft die Werbung aufgeliefert worden ist. Da trage ich auch einen App-Server, wo ich dann mein Erbemittel einsuche und dann verteile ich nur einen Link an diesen App-Server als Erbemittel weiter. Das wird dann beim nächsten Anbieter wiederum eingebunden. Das heißt, diese riesenlangen Linkketten nach hinten raus.
Ich muss mal, ob ich es richtig verstanden habe. Also ein Nutzer kommt auf eine Webseite. Ihr seht, okay, der würde für die Werbung passen und holt dann, spielt diese Werbung nicht selber aus, sondern holt dann wiederum über einen Link von einem anderen Server die Werbung ab, um sie dann zu... Jetzt beginnt es kompliziert zu werden. Ich sehe, wo wir nachher noch hinkommen.
Wir kommen dann bis zu Linkketten von 20 verschiedenen App-Servern.
Ach, tatsächlich? Warte mal, das ist ja auch ganz interessant, weil ich als Nutzer gehe auf eine Webseite und dann sozusagen sammelt... Und wann immer ich im Internet bin und auf einer Webseite bin, dann sieht ja der Betreiber dieser Webseite, dass ich da bin. Also im Sinne von er sieht meine Daten irgendwie, sieht man vielleicht meine IP-Adresse, wenn ich kein VPN benutze, oder er kann mich über meinen Browser identifizieren, er kann Cookies setzen. Wenn du jetzt sagst 20, dann heißt das, diese 20 können das wahrscheinlich auch.
Genau, die sehen das auch. Die 20 sehen das und alle schreiben sich selbst ihre Daten mit über diesen, also alle setzen in ein Cookie zum Beispiel, und die schreiben die Daten mit in das Cookie, wird immer weiter gefüllt. Je länger du das Browst, desto mehr wird in das Cookie reingeschrieben, Informationen über dich. Und darauf basiert nachher das Parallel-Thing. Mittlerweile sogar so weit, dadurch, dass ich halt, brauche ich nicht mehr ein Cookie, durch deine Rechnerkonfiguration, was der Browser, was er alles übermitteln kann an dem Server, kann ich ziemlich genau feststellen, dass du das bist und habe über dich Informationen gesammelt angeschrieben.
Das können wir gleich auch noch mal in die Show Notes packen. Es gibt da nämlich ein paar sehr schöne Seiten, wo man sich das selber angucken kann, weil ganz viele Rechner haben irgendwie ihre ganz spezielle Fonds, die nur, die sonst ganz selten sind, oder irgendwelcher Jitter von irgendwelchen Audio Interfaces, weil man mittlerweile ja auch Bild und Ton über den Browser bearbeiten kann. Das ist total faszinierend.
Und das wird benutzt, um darauf, um dann festzustellen...
Um Fingerabdruck zu bauen.
Und das ist vermutlich, also dann, wenn du die Seite aufguchst, weißt du ja, etwa, ziemlich sicher, dass das jetzt gerade der Monoxid ist. Der Rechner von Monoxid.
Ja, zum Anfang weiß er das noch nicht. Aber er baut sich dieses Bild dann über die Zeit zusammen und weiß dann, irgendwann kann er es dann korrelieren, wenn du dann irgendwann mal kaufst, dann Rechnungsadresse angebst, dann hängt da plötzlich eine Adresse und diverse Multimedia-Accounts dran.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich schon auch so, dass für die Werbetreibung gar nicht so interessant ist, ob das jetzt irgendwie Markus Richter aus Berlin ist, sondern um die geht es eher darum zu wissen, okay, dieser Typ, der ist ungefähr so und so alt, hat ungefähr so und so viel Geld und hat Interesse für die und die Sachen.
Woher weißt du das? Aber sag mal, wird uns die Europäische Union da nicht retten? Weil bei Cookies muss ja mittlerweile überall eine Warnung eingewendet werden. Wird das dann auch für Brauser Fingerprints?
Äh, nein, die gilt das nicht.
Okay, Regulierungsbedarf, ich sehe.
Ja, Regulierungsbedarf für Brauser Fingerprints, zumal auch Brauser viel zu viel übertragen mittlerweile. Das ist aber eine völlig andere Geschichte. Auf jeden Fall ist daraus eine große, ekelhafte Wirtschaft entstanden, auf diesem ganzen Targeting. Es gibt auch Anbieter, die nur Cookies setzen und nichts anderes machen und dann die Auswetterung wiederum an Etzerer verkaufen. Wir haben einen großen französischen Anbieter zum Beispiel, der es da marktführe. Ich hab den mehr als einmal implementieren müssen für Kunden. Es gibt daraus eine Wirtschaft, die sich nur mit Targeting im Internet beschäftigt. Und die greift sich dann auch nochmal Kohle ab.
Jetzt frag ich mich, wie lange hast du diesen Job gemacht?
Ich hab das drei Jahre lang gemacht. Ich war jung, ich musste Miete zahlen und hatte ein Auto abzubezahlen.
Okay, würdest du es nochmal atonen?
Um es anzuzünden, ja.
Aber jetzt bist du sozusagen jemand, der ganz genau weiß, wie es funktioniert. Wie surfst du denn im Netz?
Mit Adblockern natürlich. Ich wechsle das immer wieder mal durch, die Produkte, die es da gibt, weil ich mit allen eigentlich unzufrieden bin, weil da immer noch viel zu viel durchkommt und auch mittlerweile natürlich ganz viele Gegenmaßnahmen gegen Adblocker getroffen werden. Also nicht nur, wie bei Springer das ist, dass dann die Kündigwerte nicht besuchen kommt, das wäre ja noch irgendwie okay. Mittlerweile gab es schon, als ich noch da gearbeitet habe, auch 5 Jahre, 6 Jahre her, gab es nur die Anfrage, ob wir nicht adblocker umgehen und es gibt Methoden dafür, adblocker zu umgehen.
Okay, da sprechen wir auf jeden Fall nachher auch noch drüber. Meine Güte, das ist alles sehr ernüchternd gewesen, also für mich, ich hab tatsächlich zu sagen, so ein bisschen mich ja schon darüber informiert, aber es ist doch noch mal ernüchternd, dass sozusagen so komprimiert auf eine Stelle zusammengefasst werden. Vielen Dank, Stefan, sage ich mit etwas unguten Gesicht und viel Spaß noch und bitte ergreife als nächstes einen ordentlichen Beruf, ja? Sehr gut, dann viel Spaß und danke. So, interessant, also jetzt haben wir sozusagen eine der Schattenseiten von Werbung mal ganz ausführlich geleustet, nämlich die Daten, die dabei eingesammelt werden. Das muss man sich noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, vor Augen halten. Es ist halt nicht so, dass nur diese Webseite Daten sammelt, die Werbung schaltet. Es ist nicht so, dass es einen Betreiber von Werben gibt, der vielleicht Daten über sich sammelt, sondern es ist so, dass es eine Vielzahl an Firmen gibt, die alle mit aufgerufen werden, wenn ihr auf eine Webseite kommt, wo Werbung geschaltet ist. Und alle sammeln Daten und korrelieren die und verkaufen euch dann wiederum an andere Sachen.
Und ihr braucht euch nicht einzubilden, dass einfach nur das Cookie löschen, was ja immer gerne angepriesen wird, dafür sorgt, dass die euch vergessen. Denn was wir auch gehört haben ist, die können mittlerweile auch mit ganz anderen Mitteln euch und eurer Browser eindeutig identifizieren. Die können teilweise auch genau rausfinden, mit welchen Geräten ihr online seid. Das heißt, wenn ihr das Gerät wechselt, können die immer noch feststellen, das ist im Prinzip derselbe Typ. Und können euch trotzdem munter weiter tracken.
So, wir haben ja kurz, bevor wir sozusagen, wir kommen gleich noch dazu, was dahintersteht. Also wir haben ja auch gelernt, dass die Werbung sozusagen vielleicht möglicherweise gar nicht von dem ausgeliefert wird, der dafür eingekauft ist, Werbung auszupacken, sondern dass sie woanders herkommt. Und damit kann man auch noch Dinge anstellen. Dazu kommen wir später. Jetzt haben wir noch einen Anrufer, nämlich Du, Schan. Ich hoffe, der Name ist richtig. 22 aus Spandau. Hallo und guten Abend. Du hast eine schöne Werbegeschichte für uns.
Ich habe was?
Eine schöne Werbegeschichte für uns, eine online Werbegeschichte.
Ja, ich habe einige Werbegeschichten. Und zwar, ich sehr interessant finde jetzt, dass man hauptsächlich nur über Werbebahner auf Webseiten geredet hat. Wie sieht es aber aus, zum Beispiel mit Werbung, die auf YouTube geliefert wird? Klar, es gibt Werbebahner, die da zwischendurch weggeblockt werden durch Adblocker, Werbevideos, die am Anfang des Videos weggeblockt werden. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es ja auch Product Placement. Und damit verdienen sich beispielsweise YouTuber ja Tausenden von Euros beispielsweise. Und die sind zum Beispiel nicht weggeblockt. Das heißt, wenn ich auf ein Video gehe, was beispielsweise nur am Ende des Videos angezeigt wird, dass es durch Produktplacement unterstützt wird, wie gehe ich damit um? Also bin ich absichtlich auf dieses YouTube-Video gegangen, weil ich eben nur diesen Inhalt sehen wollte, diesen YouTuber halt, oder halt wirklich ein Product, was halt dementsprechend für das halt beworben wird. Und das ist halt auch eine interessante Geschichte. Das heißt, eine einzige Person oder mehrere Personen jeweils, der sozusagen diesen Kanal betreibt, bei dem sich für ein einziges Video, was eigentlich geblockt wird, durch eine andere Firma, die sozusagen will, dass dieses Produkt geworben wird, tausenden von Euros, je nachdem natürlich wie der Kanal erfolgreich ist. Das heißt, das ist natürlich auch noch so eine andere Schattenseite, die sozusagen erst meistens sozusagen erst am Ende eines Videos zum Beispiel.
Ja, es gibt auch eine Firma, die sich darauf spezialisiert hat, genau dieses Problem anzugehen. Ich habe den Namen jetzt nicht, aber ich habe den Link mal schon mal beiseite gepackt. Und die bieten an, gib mir irgendein Video und wir sorgen dafür, dass was immer du da gerade in die Kamera gehalten hast, in quasi Echtzeit ausgetauscht wird durch ein anderes Produkt, sodass du dann die Dinge an den Zielmarkt anpassen kannst. Das hast du wahrscheinlich schon mal im Fußball gesehen, dass die Bandenwerbung in jedem Land, wo man das sieht, anders beschaltet wird. Und sowas gibt es jetzt inzwischen auch für den Endkundenmarkt, sodass man einfach sagen kann, ich habe hier gerade mal irgendeine Dose von Pupsikola in die Kamera gehalten und irgendwie alle in einem Land, wo die andere Firma gesagt hat, wir wollen mal, dass unsere Marke eingeblendet wird, dann kriegen wir die andere Marke zu sehen. Also dieses Problem ist schon angegangen worden von der Werbeindustrie und da gibt es Lösungen inzwischen.
Kann man das dann auch als Endkunde weiterverwenden und einfach alle Cola-Flaschen durch ein Cola ersetzen?
Aber falls ich dich richtig verstanden habe, dir geht es darum, dass du quasi den Content rezipiert hast und am Ende erst gesagt bekommst, dass du im Prinzip Werbung untergeschoben bekommen hast. Na ja, im Prinzip ist das so ein bisschen so eine Weiterführung von diesen gesponserten Artikeln von Bloggern. Da hast du das teilweise auch. Wenn sie nett sind, dann schreiben sie das schon in die Überschrift. Wenn sie nicht so nett sind, dann schreiben sie irgendwie am Ende des Contents übrigens. Den Artikel, den ich hier beschrieben hab, den habe ich kostenlos oder unter anderen Umständen von einem Werbepartner bekommen, damit ich den hier bespreche. Ich glaube, da muss man eigentlich relativ streng sein. Wenn man sagt, das ist mir zu doof, dann muss man die Leute halt mit nicht angucken bestrafen. Weil so viele Klicks sind eigentlich das, was denen am meisten weh tut. Und das ist halt dadurch, dass sie so eine große Masse von Leuten haben, die sich ja wahrscheinlich weniger disziplinieren können, schwierig. Aber ich fürchte, eine andere Möglichkeit hast du da individuell nicht. Natürlich nicht.
Ich wollte es nur sozusagen ansprechen, dass es auch Inhalte gibt, die eben nicht durch einen Adblocker zu blocken sind.
Völlig richtig.
Also noch nicht zu blocken.
Genau, aber das ist halt diese Fortführung von dem, was Erdgeist gerade erzählt hat, nämlich dass es werbliche Inhalte in Print- und Online-Medien gibt. Das zieht sich dann über, also das wäre für mich sozusagen eine folgerichtige Weiterleitung. Dann gibt es das auf Blogs und dann gibt es das eben auch auf YouTube. Das ist eigentlich nur so eine Weiterführung, aber ist natürlich vollkommen richtig, ja.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch, was ich vielleicht noch erzählen wollte, beispielsweise natürlich auch schwarze Seiten in unserem Web 2.0, wo es natürlich nicht so einfach ist, diese zu finanzieren. Meistens ist es ja so, dass diese schwarzen Seiten dementsprechend, seien es z.B. Foren, die für bestimmte Spielebots anbieten oder jegliche andere Inhalte, dass die zum Beispiel natürlich auch gucken müssen, wie finanziell ich denn dieses Forum oder dieses Projekt. Und dementsprechend, das ist natürlich dann eben nicht so leicht. Wenn man zum Beispiel an eine Firma rankam, kann man eben nicht, weil man eben beispielsweise die Firmensitze braucht. Und wie man beispielsweise einige Seiten kennt, sind diese Firmensitze komischerweise natürlich in Hongkong oder in irgendwelchen asiatischen Städten. Und obwohl natürlich einige Firmen natürlich dazu anfordern, wo ist denn deine Steuernummer? Wo sind die Daten deiner Firma? Das hat nicht dem Sinne Werbung zu tun, dass man natürlich gucken muss, welche Werbefirma suche ich aus, damit ich sozusagen Werbung schalten kann. Und dementsprechend gibt es natürlich Seiten, die eben umso weniger Daten von dir fordern, was natürlich am Ende rauskommt, dass du viel weniger Einnahmen dafür bekommst, für Klicks, für Views auf diese Werbebahner, speziell für Webseiten, aber trotzdem sozusagen angeboten werden. Und so angeboten werden, dass eben Adblocker dagegen meist nichts anrichten können. Das heißt, hier ist es zum Beispiel so, dass sozusagen diese schwarzen Seiten dementsprechend sich gezielt Werbeanbieter suchen, die ebenso auch gezielt diese Seiten suchen, um dementsprechend nicht tatsächlich angeboten zu können.
Ich verstehe nicht ganz, worauf du hinauswirst. Meinst du, dass es dubiose Seiten gibt, die auch dubiose Werbung schalten? Ah, okay, sehr gut. So, jetzt sind wir schon sehr tief im Werbesumpf und sind auch schon bei der Werbung, gegen die wir technisch nichts machen können, kurz vorbeigeschippert. Wir werden uns im Verlauf...
Da gibt es noch diese eine Anekdote, dass wir neulich im Windows-Startmenü von Windows 10 auf Werbung aufgetaucht haben.
Da wird jetzt schon was mitgeliefert. Du hast ganz viele Dinge, die in deinem Startmenü auftauchen, die gar nicht wirklich installiert sind, sondern die installiert werden, wenn du das erst mal draufklickst.
Das sind Apps, die musst du dann kaufen.
Wie kommen die da rein?
Microsoft hat mitgeliefert, für Geld wahrscheinlich.
Das kriegst du jetzt schon kostenlos aufgenötigt, dann sei doch bitte so gut und guck dir auch die Werbung an.
Es gibt da ein Häkchen, das man wegmachen kann, wenn man es gefunden hat.
Ah, wie immer, könnte man das auch in den Show notes verlinken. Wir hören jetzt eine kurze Musik von Soundtrim Ambient Background. Das hört sich auch so ein bisschen nach Werbungsmusik an. Dann gibt es den Nördnews und dann machen wir hier weiter im Online-Werbungs-Chaos-Radio im Blumen. Das Chaos Radio in Blue Moon wäre nicht das Chaos Radio in Blue Moon, wenn es sich auch ordentliche Nerd-News gäbe. Verfasst wurden die vom Chaos Computer Club und präsentiert werden sie von Timo Maschewski.
Android hat ein Problem. Es gibt zwar aktuelle Versionen des Betriebssystems, die werden aber kaum installiert. Das Problem Android-Hersteller Google kann die monatlichen Updates nur für Geräte der hauseigenen Nexus-Serie anbieten. Bei allen anderen Modellen hängt die Geschwindigkeit, mit der Updates zur Verfügung gestellt werden, von Smartphone-Herstellern und Mobilfunkanbietern ab. Google hat jetzt die Nase voll und führt seit Jahresanfang eine Liste, mit der Hersteller nach ihrer Update-Fähigkeit bewertet werden, vorerst im Geheimen. Aber sollte sich das Update-Verhalten nicht bessern, will Google die Liste notfalls öffentlich machen, um so die anderen Hersteller unter Druck zu setzen. Die aktuelle Android-Versionsnummer beginnt übrigens mit einer 6. Ihr könnt ja mal gucken, wie aktuell die Software auf eurem Telefon ist. Die Entwickler des Verschlüsselungs-Trojaners Cerber haben die Fähigkeiten des Internet-Ungeziefers erweitert. Bislang verschlüsselte Cerber nur die Festplatte und sperrte den Rechner bis zur Zahlung eines Lösegeldes. Nun lässt er seine Opfer auch für sich arbeiten. Auf Kommando bombardieren infizierte Rechner laut Sicherheitsforschern ausgewählte Ziele mit Anfragen. Damit können die Betreiber gleich zweimal Geld abgreifen. Die so angegriffenen müssen ebenfalls zahlen, um die Angriffswelle zu beenden. Vergleichsweise gute Nachrichten gibt es hingegen für Opfer des Erpressungs Trojaners Tesla Crypt. Dessen Entwickler haben jetzt den Master Key veröffentlicht, mit dem sich alle befallenen Rechner entschlüsseln lassen. Mit dem ESET Tesla Crypt Decrypter steht eine kostenlose Entschlüsselungssoftware zur Verfügung, mit der Betroffenen ihre Daten zurückbekommen können. Den Link findet ihr in den Show Notes zur Sendung auf Chaosradio.ccc.de.
Die NerdNews, präsentiert von Timo Maschewski. Vielen Dank. Fritz. Zwei Sprechstunden. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Ich begrüße ganz herzlich Erdgeist, Danimo und Henrik vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo. Und wir reden heute über Online-Werbung und haben in der ersten Stunde schon mal geklärt, was das überhaupt ist, was man für schöne Erlebnisse damit schon hatte. Wir könnten auch anrufen 0331 77 97 110 und haben mit Stefan gesprochen, einem ehemaligen Online-Werbungsarbeiter, könnte man sagen, der erklärt hat, dass im Hintergrund von so Werbung, die wir im Internet sehen, eine Vielzahl von Firmen stehen, die auf der Webseite dann dafür zuständig sind, dass da die Werbung erscheint. Und er hat erklärt, dass eine Firma dann arbeitet, die Daten einzusammeln, um dann auch sagen zu können, okay, die Werbung wird an ganz bestimmte Leute ausgespielt. Wir haben gelernt, dass wir total überwacht werden und dass nicht nur die Cookies diese Daten von uns beinhalten, sondern dass wir auch anhand unserer Browser identifiziert werden können. Und bevor wir noch zu dem Schabernack kommen, wollten noch kurz Henrik und Erdkreis was dazu sagen.
Na, was der Stefan erzählt hat, ist ja nicht der ganz aktuelle Stand. Es gibt inzwischen wirklich einen aktiven Handel, der irgendwie mit diesem High-Frequency-Trading von Aktien vergleichbar ist. Wie heißt das in Deutschland? Hochgeschwindigkeitshandel?
Ich glaube, man sagt das einfach ganz basi.
Und dabei ist es so, dass wenn du die Webseite aufrufst, dann wird einfach noch während deiner Seite ladet kommuniziert innerhalb des Netzwerks. Du, da gibt es gerade irgendjemanden, der klickt die Seite, der will da Werbung angeblendet bekommen. Gibt es da irgendwelche Interessanten? Und dann kann man sich innerhalb von Sekundenbruchteilen als Werbetreibende dafür anbieten. Ja, nehme ich, wenn das irgendwie nur so und so viel kostet. Und dann wird da der Anbieter wirklich live ausgewählt, sodass dort mit ähnlichen Problemen die Werbeanbieter inzwischen zu kämpfen haben, wie die HFT-Trader, die ihre Server dann immer noch eine Mikrosekunde näher an den Handelsplatz ranstellen, um dann da eher dabei zu sein.
Also das heißt, ich werde versteigert quasi als Nutzer?
Ich finde es ja auch sehr spannend, bei diesem HFT ist es ja ganz wichtig, schnell zu sein. Das heißt, man nimmt auch eher Glasfaser, weil die Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit höher ist als in Kupfer. Und näher dran, kürzere Leitungen, selbst Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Wird das dann irgendwann ein Treiber für Fiber to the Home im Entkundenmarkt?
Aber faszinierend.
Wir kriegen alle dicke Anschlüsse, damit uns schneller Werbung präsentiert werden kann.
Das ist ein echt großes Problem, dass du ja am Ende die Bandbreite dafür bezahlen musst, dass die Werbung auf dein Endgerät gespielt wird.
Und gerade die Mobile Betreiber finden das auch echt scheiße.
Halt, halt, halt, halt. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle fragen, da hab ich jetzt die ganze Zeit noch gar nicht dran gedacht. Ich lade ja tatsächlich nicht nur die Webseite, ich lade ja auch noch die Werbung. Das ist ja obendrauf, das heißt die Webseite wäre kleiner, wenn keine Werbung drin wäre. Dazu sind noch ungefähr, also nicht ungefähr, aber sozusagen wir haben jetzt als Daumenzahl gehört, das können auch mal 20 sein, Leute, die in dieser Werbung drin hängen, die also ihre eigenen Cookies setzen. Wie viel größer wird denn so eine Webseite, die ich mir lade, dadurch, dass Werbung drin ist?
Oh, ich glaube, da haben wir jemanden am Telefon, der uns dazu Auskunft geben kann.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Hallo.
Von ganz weit draußen zugeschaltet, THS. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich kann leider nicht im Studio sein, aber das geht, glaube ich, auch so.
Nächstes Mal wieder. Du hast dir mal genauer angeschaut, wie das technisch aussieht. Und jetzt war gerade meine Frage, ich kam gerade so drauf, wie viel größer ist denn eigentlich eine Webseite, dadurch, dass die Werbung noch mitbringt?
Naja, wie viel größer die wird, habe ich nicht nachgeschaut. Ich habe halt mal geguckt. Also ich habe mich mit dem Thema aus einem ganz anderen Grund beschäftigt, weil ich um die Sicherheit der Rechner bange, die ja eben durch so Online-Werbenetzwerke halt auch ein bisschen minimiert wird. Und da hat mich mal interessiert, wie viele Requests setzt so ein Browser eigentlich ab, wenn man so ein Newsportal unsurft und dann da so zwei Minuten drauf rumklickt. Und da habe ich mal verschiedene Newsportale angeschaut und mal mitgeschnitten, was die so für Anfragen an Web-Server stellen.
Moment, du meinst jetzt Nachrichtenseiten, ganz normale Nachrichtenseiten. Und du wolltest sagen, von wie viel Servern dann die Informationen zusammenkommen, bis die Webseite vollständig angezeigt ist?
Korrekt. Also bis die Webseite vollständig angezeigt ist, so detailliert nun nicht. Also ich hab halt mal so zwei Minuten lang auf ein paar Artikel geklickt und zwei Rubriken Ressourcen angeschaut. Und dann hab ich mal verglichen und einfach mal geguckt, wie viele Server werden überhaupt kontaktiert und wie viele Server gehören dem Verlag eigentlich selber. Und das war eigentlich ganz interessant. Also ich hab da mal zum Beispiel bei Bild.de geguckt, bei Spiegel online, bei der Süddeutschen und der Zeit online. Und um jetzt einfach mal ein paar Zahlen in den Raum zu werfen, wir haben bei Sponnen und Bild.de bei zwei Minuten rumsurfen werden insgesamt um die 2500 HTTP-Anfragen vom Webbrowser an irgendwelche Server geschickt. Also 2500 mal fragt der Webbrowser irgendwelche Web-Server nach Daten.
Wie viele verschiedene Web-Server? Also mal abgesehen davon, dass es ganz schön viel ist, davon dass es nicht eine Webseite auch. Wie viele Server sind es, die da kontaktiert werden?
Das sind rund 180 bis 190 Server, also unterschiedliche Server. Und insgesamt, da ähneln sich zum Beispiel Bild und Sponnen und die Süddeutsche. Die Server, die von denen selber betrieben werden, liegen so im zweistelligen Bereich bei 12 oder 13 Stück. Das heißt, von 190 Servern, die bei Bild e eine Rolle spielen, wenn man da so drauf rumserft, gehören Bild quasi 13 Stück selber. Das heißt, nur über diese 13 Server haben die selbst die Kontrolle.
Warte, ich möchte ganz kurz sagen, es hat nicht direkt was mit Tüner, aber warum braucht man als eine Webseite 13 verschiedene Server, um eine Webseite anzuzeigen? Kannst du das kurz für technisch Unversierten erklären?
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar kein technisches Problem, sondern eher ein organisatorisches. Ich habe jetzt diese verschiedenen Serverbild oder Sponnen oder wem auch immer nur so zugeordnet, dass ich gesehen habe, okay, das ist eine Hostname oder eine Domain, die gehören quasi dem Verlag. So habe ich herausgefunden oder eben einfach mal angenommen, dass das die Server sind, die dem Verlag selber gehören.
Also quasi irgendwas mit spiegel.de?
Genau, und dann haben die halt irgendwie einen Host, einen Server für statische Inhalte wie Bilder, dann haben sie einen für eine bestimmte Rubrik, also bei bild.de, da gibt es ja dann irgendwie noch so autobild und so weiter. So kommt das halt zu den 13 eigenen Servern und das ist jetzt nicht so, ja, also wundert mich hinfalls nicht, dass so eine größere Webseite halt irgendwie so die Sachen so organisiert hat.
Du musst nicht lachen, teilweise sind die Services auch auf mehrere Server aufgeteilt, um den Datenverkehr zu reduzieren, weil du ja, also Cookies sendet dein Browser immer dorthin, wenn sie von einem Server kamen. Wenn du jetzt also irgendwie auf Spiegel gewesen bist und von denen, wie wir gehört haben, ganz viele Cookies eingesammelt hast, und du aber manchmal irgendwelche Ressourcen möchtest, die gar keine Cookies brauchen, dann tun sie die auf den extra Server, damit dein Browser dorthin nicht die Cookies senden muss. Die haben sich dieses Problem gemacht und dann lösen sie das Problem, indem sie einfach mehr Server machen.
Ja, aber die Datenmengen, die dann da vom Client Richtung Server übertragen werden, sind ja vergleichsweise gering. Also wenn man sich dann mal anschaut im Verhältnis zu irgendwelchen Werbevideos, die dann mal runtergeladen werden.
Die Bandbreite ist auch deutlich geringer nach oben.
Aber da gibt es noch sozusagen die anderen 177 Server, die jetzt noch übrig sind. Was machen die?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Da kann man sich ja mal hinsetzen und das mal ganz genau anschauen. Also da fallen wirklich hunderte von Megabyte an, wenn man da mal so ein bisschen drauf rumklickt auf diesen ganzen Newsportalen. Und diese ganzen Daten, die da von diesen 190, 180 Servern geladen werden, das müsste man sich halt mal alles genau anschauen. Aber im Grunde genommen weiß man es eh nicht und normalen User interessiert das halt auch nicht, weil die Webseite wird angezeigt, fertig.
Markus hat ja vorhin schon erzählt, was er da sieht. Es sind genau dann unten diese Clickbait-Bilder, wo die sich auch keine Gedanken darum machen, wie groß diese Bilder jetzt sind, weil, herrje, die interessiert nicht, dass der Mobiluser da nur schmale Bandbreite hat und dann wird unten genau diese Box da eingeblendet, wo sie hoffen, dass da jemand draufklickt und dann natürlich die Werbebanner und natürlich das ganze Tracking. Da hängt ja auch ziemlich viel JavaScript dran, also dieser Code, der im Browser ausgeführt wird. Das muss ja am Ende irgendwie aus dem Internet auch auf die Rechner der Benutzer drauf.
Ja, da gibt es ganz viele Requests, die mit der Werbung zu tun haben. Da werden dann irgendwelche Tracking-URLs aufgerufen und irgendwelche JavaScripts gezogen, die dann wieder irgendwelche JavaScripte von anderen Servern ziehen, nur um am Ende irgendeinen Werbebanner anzuzeigen. Das ist ja, Entschuldigung, wir haben ja hier so etwas wie ein Adwar. Also die Werbetreibenden oder die Werbenetzwerke versuchen ja auch immer die Werbeblocker quasi auch auszutricksen und so weiter. Und ich denke, dass da halt auch viele unnötige Requests gemacht werden, nur um diesen Krieg irgendwann zu gewinnen.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, kommst du an der Stelle ins Spiel, die wir vorhin schon mal kurz erläutert hatten, nämlich Stefan hat uns erzählt, dass die Werbung, die ausgeliefert wird, kommt ja nicht unbedingt von den Werbetreibenden oder der Agentur, die für die Online-Werbe zuständig ist, sondern als jemand, der Online-Werbung schaltet, kann ich auch sagen, ich möchte gerne, dass ihr die Online-Werbung von mir abholt. Also sagen, was da konkret im Browser angezeigt wird, dass es auf meinem Server liegt.
Und da kommst du doch jetzt ins Spiel, oder? Naja, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld habe, Stefan hatte das ja gesagt, wenn man mehr Geld in die Hand nimmt, dann kann man halt schon sehr genau spezifizieren, wie die Zielgruppe für meine Werbung aussehen soll. Nicht wahr? Also das geht dann schon. Ansonsten weiß ich nicht.
Aber auch eine Inhalte platzieren, das ist ja das Spannende. Also wirklich nicht nur sagen, ich hab hier ein Bildchen, zeig mal an. Sondern halt durchaus mehr.
Chart Software zum Beispiel. Und das ist eben der Grund, warum ich mich überhaupt mit dieser ganzen Thematik mal befasst habe. Weil mir das einfach zu wenig diskutiert wurde. Als diese AdWars losging, wo Bild.de angefangen hat, den Programmierer eines Umgehungswerkzeuges oder Algorithmuses. Das fing halt irgendwie an, dass Bild.de ja Adblocker ausgesperrt hat. Und es dann Leute gab, die gesagt haben, diese Sperre kann ich auch umgehen. Dann fing das halt an, dass es da eine juristische Auseinandersetzung gab. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, Leute, ihr sprecht hier die ganze Zeit über Adblocker. Dass ihr die Adblocker nutzt, um sich nur diesen ganzen bunten Werbekram nicht anzuzeigen. Mir geht es halt auch noch um die Sicherheit meines Rechners. Ich wollte halt da mal so ein bisschen das Bewusstsein dafür schaffen, dass das halt ein durchaus größeres Problem ist als unästhetische Werbung. Denn der Browser, der ja all diese ganzen Daten verarbeitet und ohne dass man die auch bewusst abruft von irgendwelchen Servern, der ist erstmal mit Chartsoftware konfrontiert. Und ja, da wollte ich einfach mal zeigen, was das für Konsequenzen und Folgen hat.
Du hast ja zu sagen, du definierst aber jetzt als Chartsoftware alles, was quasi nicht Webseite ist, die ich mir angucken will. Also quasi, ich gehe auf eine Nachrichtenwebseite und dann sagst du, Chartsoftware ist erstmal alles, was nicht zu der Webseite gehört.
Ja, nicht alles. Also Chartsoftware hat halt schon einen sehr speziellen Zweck, irgendwie den Benutzer in die Irre zu führen, den zu irgendeiner dummen Aktion zu verleiten oder eben, weiß ich, Schwachstellen auf dem Computer auszunutzen zum Beispiel. Also das sind eben Dinge, davon kriegt der Nutzer selber gar nichts mit oder der weiß auch nicht, dass er sich überhaupt in diese Gefahr begibt.
Ja, aber ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich hatte ja ganz am Anfang der Sendung erzählt, Werbung, die quasi mehr oder weniger irreführend ist und die mich dazu verleiten soll, was anzuklicken. Aber jetzt hast du gesagt, Lücken ausnutzen, das klingt ja wie ein Virus. Geht das tatsächlich über Online-Werbung?
Jaja klar, das geht. Das dachte er einfach. Natürlich geht das. Nein, also wenn wir uns jetzt einfach mal so, also wenn wir jetzt mal schauen, wie können wir Schadsoftware verbreiten. Unter Schadsoftware verstehe ich dann zum Beispiel so Sachen wie diese Krypto-Trojaner, Ransomware wie Loki und all diese ganzen Geschichten. Aber zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Staats-Trojaner oder irgendwie Schadsoftware, die am Ende darauf aus sind, Geld von den Benutzer zu bekommen. Online-Banking-Trojaner und all diese ganzen Geschichten, die fängt man sich ja irgendwie ein. Oft werden die per E-Mail verschickt. Heutzutage öffnet aber keiner mehr so einen E-Mail-Anhang so leichtfertig und klickt dann auf irgendwelche Dateien, die von irgendwelchen fremden Leuten geschickt werden. Aber der Browser, der kriegt die angeboten, der lädt die runter und dann fühlt er halt ein bisschen Nervous-Script-Code aus und mit ein bisschen Pech hat der Browser halt gerade einen Bug und sorgt halt dafür, dass diese Schadsoftware dann auch auf dem Rechner installiert wird.
Moment, Moment, Moment, halt. Jetzt kann man ja den online Werbetreibenden viel nachsagen. Sie sammeln unsere Daten, sie belästigen uns und so weiter und so fort. Aber entschuldige, die werden noch nicht sozusagen Schadsoftware in die Werbung einbinden.
Ja, doch, das tun sie einfach, weil sie ja die Kontrolle verloren haben.
Halt. Also ich kann doch da hingehen und sagen, hier, ich möchte für WLAN-Kabel werben und hier ist mein tolles Banner und das zeigt er jetzt bitte an und dann gebe ich denen das und die machen das. Punkt.
Die gucken nicht nach?
Was sollen die denn nachgucken? Ob das WLAN-Kabel kippt oder was?
Nein, nein, nein, warte, warte, warte. Also nur um das sozusagen Schritt für Schritt zu machen. Also du gehst halt hin und sagst, ich möchte eine Werbung schalten. Und zwar diese Werbung ist hier. So soll die Werbung aussehen. Also die Werbung ist anscheinend nicht nur ein Bild, also was man wirklich übergibt, sondern es ist ein Programmcode. Und denen gucken die nicht nach, was der macht?
Ja, nein, das tun sie nicht.
Das ist ein automatisiertes Prozess, du überweist das Geld und...
Selbst wenn sie es täten, wir kommen ja dann, also wenn sie den Content überprüfen würden, der von den Werben denn da submitted wird, dann haben wir ja so ein Sicherheitsmodell, und ich würde das gerne in Anführungszeichen setzen, wie diese Appstores von Microsoft, Apple, Android und so weiter. Da werden halt Anwendungen hingeschickt, die prüfen dann diese Anwendungen nach diversen Kriterien und sagen halt so, ja, ist eine tolle Anwendung, ist jedenfalls keine Schadsoftware, ist jetzt also sicher, weil ist jetzt im Appstore. Und da wurde ja in der Vergangenheit auch schon oft genug gezeigt, dass selbst solche Securitychecks oder eben solche Überprüfungen der Apps, dass man die halt auch leicht umgehen kann. Und das ist hier um ein Vielfaches einfacher, weil die Werbenetzwerke ja auch vorsehen, dass du den Content selber bereitstellst auf deinen eigenen Servern. Werbetreibende, die halt sagen, ja, ich möchte auch niemanden belästigen. Ich möchte halt auch nicht, dass ich die Webseite langsamer aufbaue, nur weil ich hier mein eigenes Werbebanner habe. Die werden halt sagen so, ne, ne, packt das mal bei euch in die Cloud, dann kommt das bei den Nutzern halt auch schnell an und die Webseite lädt sich schnell. Aber man hat die Möglichkeit, das auf einem eigenen Webserver zu tun. Und wer hindert mich dann daran, meinen eigenen JavaScript-Code und mein eigenes Programm, was ich da in das Werbe-Netzwerk gedrückt habe, zehn Minuten später auszutauschen?
Ja, entschuldige mal, das ist doch ein riesig, riesig großes Scheuntor, wo jetzt sozusagen als kriminelle Natur, würde ich denken, also wenn ich jetzt zum ersten Mal höre so, was für eine geile Idee, ich werde sofort meine ganze Schadsoftware nur noch über Online-Werbung verbreiten. Jetzt schreien aber nicht alle, dass ihre Rechner infiziert werden wollen. Also wie realistisch ist denn das Bedrohungs-Szenario?
Das ist sehr realistisch. Ich hab das selber gemacht. Im Rahmen eines Vortrags habe ich das mal demonstriert, dass ich eine Schadsoftware hochladen kann. Und da habe ich zwei verschiedene Exploits für Firefox Webbrowser über dieses Ad-Netzwerk verbreitet.
Kurz Exploits, kleine Programme, die Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen.
Genau, und die sorgen dann dafür, dass so eine Schadsoftware installiert werden kann. Statt einer Schadsoftware habe ich dann nur den Taschenrechner gestartet. Aber das sollte zumindest mal demonstrieren, dass das durchaus möglich ist. Und das passierte ja auch in der letzten Zeit sehr oft, dass einige Webseiten Schadsoftware verteilt haben. Also da gibt es einige in Deutschland, Europa, auf der ganzen Welt, gibt es viele Verlage, die da völlig hilflos zusehen mussten, wie ihr Werbepartner, ihr Werbenetzwerk, die Leser des Newsmagazins mit Schadsoftware zugeschrissen haben.
Erst letzte Woche gerade hat irgendwie eine große deutsche Online-Zeitung sämtliche Werbung schnell abgeschaltet, weil einer ihrer Werbepartner dort...
Und das interessante dabei ist, dass es jetzt auch ganz gezielt auf den Mobile-Bereich ging. Also das war ja eine sehr stark auf den mobilen Leserkreis zugeschnittene Werbung. Das heißt, das war halt so diese andere Variante. Da wurden nicht Exploits und so weiter verschickt. Das waren dann so Overlay-Geschichten, um die Leute zu täuschen. Also das geht dann so ein bisschen in Richtung Social Engineering.
Ihr PC ist infiziert, klicken Sie jetzt hier, um diese Desinfektionssoftware runterzuladen.
Und das kennt man ja aus E-Mails. Ihr kriegt auch immer wieder mal E-Mails, wo drinnen steht so hier, hier ist eine Rechnung. Wenn du die bis morgen nicht bezahlt hast, steht das ein Kassounternehmen bei dir vor der Tür. Und in dem Moment, wo der Benutzer so eine Information liest und das irgendwie plausibel für ihn ist, wird er darauf reagieren und dann da halt draufklicken. Also wenn da eine Rechnung von der Telekom kommt oder irgendeinem anderen Dienstleister, wo der Benutzer irgendwie in der letzten Zeit was eingekauft hat, dann kann das durchaus sein, dass er dann auf irgendein PDF klickt, was schadhafte Inhalte hat. Und genauso funktioniert das dann in diesen Werbenetzwerken mit so einem JavaScript-Overlay-Geschichten. Da wird dem Nutzer einfach gesagt, so, uah, du hast hier ein Virus, klick hier, um den Virus zu entfernen. Und in Wirklichkeit lädt er dadurch erst in Wirklichkeit die Schadsoftware herunter und installiert die. Aber es erscheint ihm in diesem Moment plausibel. Und deswegen ist es auch noch sehr verbreitet, auf dieser Social-Engineering-Ebene solche Angriffe zu fahren. Das betraf jetzt hier in diesem Fall, was Erdgeser angesprochen hat, tatsächlich nur mobile Clients. Die haben halt so für Mobile Clients spezielle Werbepartner. Und da haben sie dann eben, je nachdem, ob dann Android oder ein iPhone ankam, gesagt, so ja hier, update mal auf die aktuelle Version.
Aber das heißt ja, wenn ich dieses Targeting mir zu Ende denke, man kann ja wahrscheinlich nicht nur sagen, ich möchte sozusagen junge 22-jährige Männer aus Trepplo Köpenick, sondern ich möchte auf Leute targeten, die den Firefox benutzen. Müsste doch gehen, oder?
Ja, das geht ganz einfach. Aber das kann auch am Ende des Javascript entscheiden, ob es jetzt irgendwie einen Exploit ausprobiert.
Ich will ja meine Werbung mit dem Startcode nur dort schalten, wo der Startcode auch wirklich anschlägt, oder?
Vielleicht will man sich vorher noch die Kunden aussuchen, die wirklich Geld haben. Also vielleicht eher Manager-Magazin als irgendwo auf build.de oder so.
Das ist ja nach Postleitzahl.
Wenn du die Rechner von irgendwelchen Vorständen zerhacken willst, dann inserierst du halt wahrscheinlich nicht im Angelmagazin, sondern tatsächlich im Managermagazin.
Holy shit, möchte ich an dieser Stelle mal sagen.
Ansonsten, was Bert gerade noch nicht angesagt hat, ist, dass du als Werbetreibender auch selber Ziel eines Angriffs sein kannst. Du musst ja nicht mal selber deinen Kunden was Böses wollen, sondern wenn du erst mal in so einem Werbenetzwerk drin bist und dort die Reichweite hast, kannst du natürlich auch selber angegriffen werden, damit dein Content ausgetauscht wird.
Warte mal, ich hab ne Idee. Die Leute, also diese Adserve Companies, die die Werbung verteilen, die benutzen ja dazu wahrscheinlich ne Software. Und diese Software kann Sicherheitslücken haben? Und ist online? Das heißt, man kann die also auch angreifen und dann...
Und der andere Punkt, der vorhin noch zu kurz gekommen ist, Entschuldige, wenn ich nicht unterbreche, ist, dass es nicht unbedingt irgendwie groß JavaScript irgendwas braucht. Es war irgendwie vor einem Monat oder zwei ging rum, dass für das ziemlich häufig verwendete Bildformat PNG auf den Geräten mit dem Apfel drauf so ein Problem gab, wenn dort, naja, Leute daran rumgefummelt haben. Also PNG ist ein Bildformat. Genau. Und wenn du dann Bilder in diesem Format auf deinem Apple Endgerät dir angeguckt hast, dann ist da der Browser geplatzt und hat irgendwas ausgeführt, was du nicht wolltest. Das heißt, du musst da nicht mal Javascript, Mammel, Magie deployen, sondern es reicht, wenn du in das Werbenetzwerk speziell vor präparierte PNGs reist. Und wenn die dann nicht noch mal explizit angeguckt werden, was aber glücklicherweise einige ISPs, also einige mobile Netzanbieter, dann schon gemacht haben, die dann bestimmte Dinge rausgefiltert haben, wo sie wussten, das ist die Telefone.
Was man eigentlich auch nicht will. Das ist ja sozusagen das Internetprovider, die eigentlich die Datenseite verschlüsselt ist. Ich möchte an THS noch zwei Fragen stellen, die ich loswerden möchte, bevor wir ihn wieder entlassen. Die erste ist, das heißt also, Online-Werbung abschalten durch den Adblocker oder was auch immer ist nicht nur sinnvoll für den Datenschutz und weil ich damit Platz spare, sondern es minimiert, also es macht die Sicherheitsschwankung, wie ich mich jetzt aussetze, auch kleiner. Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Genau, so sehe ich das auf jeden Fall.
Und dann komme ich auf Webseiten, wo dann gesagt wird, hey, du hast einen Adblocker und wir sind doch eigentlich cool. Also du bist cool. Wir sind auch eine coole Webseite. Und vielleicht wird es ja doch, damit wir Geld verdienen können. Aber in dem Fall sollte ich deiner Meinung nach sagen, so nähe ich das den Adblocker an, weil ihr könnt mir gar nicht garantieren, dass das, was ihr mir als Werbung anzeigt, wirklich sauber ist.
Korrekt. Die Verlage können das einfach nicht garantieren, weil die haben, die kriegen ja diesen Inhalt nicht ein einziges Mal zu sehen. Also die spielen ja nicht mal Proxy oder so. Die sagen halt nur, hier ist der Artikel, den du gerne lesen wolltest. Und im Übrigen, der da hinten hat noch eine Produktinformation für dich. Lad das mal bei dem.
Okay, aber im Versuch sozusagen ausgewogen zu sein, gibt es denn überhaupt eine technische, ich red jetzt nur von einer technischen Form von Online-Werkung, wo du sagen würdest, das wäre eine Form, da könnte ich mich mit anfreunden, dass mir angezeigt wird, ich red jetzt wirklich nur von der Technik, von der Sicherheit, von der Security.
Was ist mit so Sachen, wo du nur einen Link definieren kannst, der zur richtigen Zeit aufploppt?
Ich weiß nicht, man kann die Gefahren schon einschränken, also nicht beseitigen, aber einschränken, indem man zum Beispiel sagt, wir verzichten auf bestimmte Dateiformate. Also auf einer seriösen Webseite haben irgendwie Flash-Programme oder Java-Applets einfach nichts mehr zu suchen, sieht man aber leider auch noch viel zu häufig. Das ist ein Einfallstore für allen möglichen Unsinn. Das muss halt einfach mal weg. Wenn die Verlage auch noch ein bisschen Druck auf diese Ad-Netzwerke ausüben würden, könnten die sicherlich eine weitere technische Maßnahme umsetzen, um das Risiko zu minimieren. Das heißt, man muss denen aber auf einer ganz anderen Ebene begegnen, nämlich mit Verträgen und Vertragsstrafen, wenn am Ende doch irgendwas passieren sollte. Vorher wird sich da wahrscheinlich nichts tun.
Es bleibt dir am Namen der Plattform hängen. Du klickst dann wieder in deinelieblingszeitung.de und plötzlich hast du einen Trojaner installiert und bleibt das nicht bei dem Werbenetzwerk als Imageverlust hängen, sondern bei meinelieblingszeitung.de.
Darf ich dir noch was Schlimmes zum Abschluss sagen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt noch vertrage, aber mach.
Doch, doch, doch, ganz schnell. Als TRS was gerade erwähnt hat, ging mir noch gerade in den Sinn, dass wir das im letzten Chaosradio in den NerdNews hatten. Es gibt nämlich für all das, was TRS von Hand gemacht hat, ein fertiges Exploit-Kit, das dir automatisch die Sicherheitslücken raussucht. Und du hattest nach Erfolgsquoten von sowas gefragt. Bei diesem Exploit-Kit, das nämlich analysiert wurde, zehn Prozent der angegriffenen Systeme waren auch tatsächlich exploitbar. Das heißt, die haben einfach mal mit einem Angriff 148.000 Maschinen eingesammelt. Wenn du 148.000 Maschinen irgendwie verschlüsselst, um dann da irgendwie Geld zu erpressen von, sagen wir mal, 200 Euro umgerechnet pro Maschine, dann weißt du, was da als Gewinn abfällt.
Ja, es gibt da dieses geile Framework namens Metasploit. Die haben so ein Autopone-Modul. Das hatte ich auch hier in diesem Rahmen mal mit benutzt.
Hört sich mittlerweile an, es ist wahrscheinlicher, dass ich mir was einfange, wenn ich Werbung anmache, als wenn mir Werbung angezeigt wird. Na ja, gut, das ist vielleicht noch ein kleines bisschen übertrieben. TAS, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank A, für die Arbeit, die du gemacht hast, und B, dass du uns hier versucht hast zu erklären. Danke schön.
Gern, ja, viel Spaß noch.
Ebenso mit Adblocker hoffe ich. Bis dann, tschüss.
Also was wir eigentlich wollen, sind dann am Ende reine Plain Text Werbung, ja?
Naja, aber das ist ja die Frage, ob man das so sagt. Weil selbst wenn jetzt ein Anbieter sagen würde, ich garantiere dir, dass die Werbung so und so ist, ich kann das als User nicht unterscheiden. Also Plain Text Werbung, also sagen nur reiner Text, das wäre wahrscheinlich, da würden alle Werbe treiben und sagen, das ist doof. Das heißt, man würde sich wahrscheinlich, wenn, dann darauf einigen, dass man sagt, okay, nur sozusagen Bildformate, die als sicher gelten.
Also keine.
Starship, ja.
Alle Bildformate hatten in der Vergangenheit.
Ja, aber das ist nur für die theoretische Diskussion. Also nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe sowas. Aber ich kann ja als Nutzer nicht unterscheiden, ist da sozusagen nur ein trockenes Bild eigentlich oder bringt dieses Bild wieder Kohle? Das weiß ich ja alles nicht. So ein Siegel wäre schon cool.
Und wenn sich die Verlage darauf einigen, dass alles, was an Werbeinformationen dort ausgeliefert wird, geht einmal von ihren Servern unter ihrer Kontrolle, wäre ja schon mal 90% der Einfallstore geschlossen. Man könnte dann einfach gleich darauf reagieren, wenn man merkt, dass da die eigenen Nutzer angegriffen werden und das abschalten und muss nicht darauf warten, dass es dann vielleicht der Werbepartner für einen macht.
Aber solange der Markt halt da ist, um noch eine Millisekunde vor dem Ausliefern irgendwie den maximalen Preis noch rauszuholen, solange es so läuft, wird das halt nicht passieren.
Derzeitiger Stand nach 3, 5 Stunden von 4, 5 Stunden Chaosradio ist nur noch mit Adblocker. Mehr gleich, jetzt erst mal Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Raus aus dem Alltag, rein in den Sommer.
Fritz und Festivals.
Wir präsentieren euch diesen Sommer das Kosmonautfestival mit geheimem Headliner Boi und Casper. Das Piece by Piece und das Helene Beach Festival mit Matzen Fritz Kalkbrenner und Jennifer Rostock. Das Lollapalooza und das Splash Festival mit Mac Miller, den Beginnern und Wiz Khalifa. Fritz und Festivals. Raus aus dem Alltag. Rein in den Sommer.
Fritz Nachrichten.
Mit Timo Maschewski.
Bundespräsident Gauck hat davor gewarnt, aus Angst vor Fremdem in Deutschland hysterisch zu werden. Beim Katholikentag in Leipzig sagte Gauck, wichtig sei auch zu prüfen, wie realistisch die vorgebrachten Sorgen seien. Die Erfahrungen hätten gezeigt, dass Ängste oft unbegründet sind. Als Beispiel nannte Gauck die Anti-Islam Demos in Sachsen. Dort gäbe es aber relativ wenig Menschen, die Sachsen über Fremden könnten, sagte Gauck. Dort, wo es schon viele Moscheen gäbe, gäbe es auch viel weniger Vorurteile. Wie kann die Weltwirtschaft weiter angekurbelt werden? Darüber haben die Staats- und Regierungschefs der sieben großen Industrieländer heute auf ihrem Gipfeltreffen in Japan gesprochen. Sie wollen eine Initiative verabschieden, die unter anderem dafür sorgen soll, dass die Menschen besser gebildet werden und auch mehr Frauen arbeiten können. Ein anderes wichtiges Thema war die Flüchtlingskrise. Kinsekanzlerin Merkel geht aber nicht davon aus, dass sich bei dem Gipfel Staaten konkret verpflichten, mehr Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen oder mehr Geld bereitzustellen. Mit spezieller Unterwassertechnik wollen französische Experten die Flugschreiber der verunglückten Egypt Air Maschine finden. Von Corsica aus hat sich ein Vermessungsboot auf den Weg gemacht. Es soll in den nächsten Tagen an der Absturzstelle ankommen. Das Schiff hat Detektoren an Bord, die die Signale orten können, die die Blackbox automatisch sendet. Falls auch das nichts bringt, könnte ein Unterwasser-Roboter zum Einsatz kommen. Das Egypt Air Flugzeug war vor einer Woche auf dem Weg von Paris nach Cairo ins Mittelmeer gestürzt. In Berlin nutzen bisher nur wenige arme Menschen die Möglichkeit, sich Zuschuss für die Miete zu holen. Stadtentwicklung-Senator Geisel sagte dem RBB, bisher hätten erst gut 700 Haushalte einen Antrag gestellt. 26.000 Mieter dürften das aber tun. Seit Jahresbeginn können sich Mieter den Zuschuss sichern, wenn sie in einer Sozialwohnung leben und mehr als 30 Prozent ihres Nettoeinkommens für die Miete ausgeben müssen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Treptow hat 12 Grad und Charlottenburg 15 Grad, Potsdam und Carlo melden 12 Grad, Neuropin 13 Grad und Eberswalde 14 Grad. Bis auf 8 Grad kann es sich im Laufe der Nacht noch abkühlen, der Himmel klart immer weiter auf, Regen ist erst mal nicht in Sicht. Im Laufe des Tages ziehen neue Wolken rein, die später auch Regen mit sich bringen können. Die Temperaturen bewegen sich so zwischen 20 und 23 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der A100, dem Stadtring in Richtung Wedding ist zwischen Buschkruge Allee und Gradesstraße die linke Spur gesperrt. Der Tiergarten-Tunnel ist außerdem wegen Wartungsarbeiten gesperrt, und zwar in beiden Richtungen. Vorsicht in Brandenburg auf der A10, dem westlichen Berliner Ring in Richtung Dreieckhafelland. Zwischen Föben und Leest sind Wildschweine auf der Autobahn. Vorsicht auch im Kreis Märkisch-Oderland auf der B168. Zwischen Darmstorf und dem Abzweig nach Liebenhof liegen Gegenstände. Dort, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz für die Hosentasche wollt, mit Livestream, Studio Message, Podcasts und jede Menge mehr, dann holt euch doch die Fritz-App. Kostenlos und werbefrei in eurem App oder Play Store.
Heute Chaosradio Mülmün und ich kann aus den letzten dreieinhalb Stunden schon mal sagen, wir werden alle sterben und zwar durch Online-Werbung. Also ich habe in den letzten dreieinhalb Stunden gelernt. Online-Werbung verursacht zusätzlichen Datenverkehr, es spioniert uns aus und es macht den Rechner unsicher, weil es ein Einfallstore Verscharsoftware ist. Das heißt, es spricht momentan eigentlich nichts dafür, Online-Werbung zuzulassen, weil das scheint mir...
Du hast zwar noch ein paar Dinge vergessen, aber...
Entschuldigung, du stirbst durch die Guillotine, den Galgen und Feuer. Da muss man jetzt nicht irgendwie noch die Reichstrecke, die man ziehen muss.
Das ist noch schmerzvoller als was du da gerade behauptest.
Wieso, was?
Wie dein Rechner wird noch langsamer, die Webseiten laden langsamer, bis du es ankieken kannst.
Hab ich schon gesagt.
Was?
Zusätzlicher Datending.
Nie, auch um wie der Browser führt er noch den ganzen Tag, was kommt aus?
Ja genau, das zusätzliche Datending ist zu sagen, das macht mehr Traffic. Also wenn du mobil unterwegs bist, schlürft es an deinem Guthaben. Der Akku irgendwie geht schneller runter, weil da dann Dinge ausgeführt werden, das Handy wird warm, das ist alles ganz, wie gesagt, alles ganz völlig. Tatsächlich haben uns auch die Leute, also Hörer haben gehört und Hörerinnen, und haben uns einen geschrieben. Und tatsächlich ist die erste Frage von Gino, der hat gefragt, was denn dagegen hilft getrackt zu werden. Also wir haben ja ganz am Anfang auch erklärt, dass sozusagen die Online-Werbung in den Browsern immer auch ganz genau guckt, ja wer ist denn da, wo haben wir den Schumar gesehen, was haben wir für Daten über den, und fragt, ob eine VPN dafür hilft. Mal kurz erklären, was ein VPN ist und warum das nicht hilft.
Ein VPN ist ein ziemlich großer Begriff, aber wie er denn gerade meint, ist, dass du eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zu irgendeinem Rechner im Internet herstellst und all deinen Datenverkehr nicht mehr sichtbar für dein Internetanbieter direkt bei ihm ins Internet schickst, sondern bei dem Server, mit dem du da die verschlüsselte Verbindung aufgenommen hast. Das heißt, du stopbst es einmal in einen Tunnel, auf der anderen Seite kommt aus dem Tunnel wieder raus und du erscheinst so, als ob du an irgendeiner Stelle im Internet dich befindest, wo du eigentlich gar nicht bist.
Wollen wir uns noch mal genau überlegen, was wir gerade gesagt haben. Dann kann das leider auch gar nichts bringen. Also VPNs werden immer mit Sicherheit und nicht Trackbarkeit oder so völlig zu Unrecht in Verbindung gebracht, weil am Ende steht ja immer noch der Browser. Und zwar genau der Browser, wo die Cookies drauf sind. Und der Browser, der diese einmalige Konfiguration hat, die sich wieder auslesen lässt. Und dabei ist es völlig egal, ob ich da in Triptoköpenik rauskomme oder in Timbuktu. Der Gegenseite ist das völlig egal. Der ist eigentlich total klar, das ist trotzdem immer noch derselbe Browser.
Es sei denn, man hat den Browser speziell konfiguriert, jetzt nicht als VPN, sondern Tor zum Beispiel bringt seinen eigenen Browser mit. Der versucht, all diese Fingerprinting-Möglichkeiten weitestmöglich zu umgehen. Unter anderem startet er zum Beispiel immer mit der gleichen Bildschirmgröße. Egal, wie groß sein Bildschirm ist, der Browserfenster hat immer die gleiche Größe. Wir haben uns da schon ein paar Gedanken gemacht. Das Versuch, das weitestgehend zu umgehen, ist natürlich auch nicht perfekt.
Es hat jetzt nicht direkt was mit zu tun, aber er fragt außerdem noch, ob es einen VPN auch so was wie kostenlos gibt. Da ist die Antwort eher nein. Beziehungsweise, wenn es einen kostenlosen VPN gibt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich...
Tor ist eigentlich ein kostenloses VPN.
Ja, also es gibt diesen wunderschönen Spruch, wenn du nicht dafür bezahlst, bist du nicht der Kunde, sondern das Produkt. Opera hat dich gerade zum Produkt gemacht. Also Opera ist ein Browserhersteller, die bieten gerade so was an, was sie VPN nennen, was aber im wesentlichen bloßen Webproxy ist. Und deren Deal ist halt, wir verschleien eure IP-Adresse, dafür leitet ihr allen euren Treffik über uns und wir können den sehen. Also ob man das jetzt machen will.
Hey, das heißt nicht mein Internetanbieter kann mich verfolgen, sondern ein Opera. Gut. Zweite Frage von Roberto, der fragt... Ach so, bei dem geht es um Handy-Ding. Und er sagt sozusagen, naja, okay, das heißt, wenn ich die Werbung auf dem Handy runterlade, dann zerrt das ja tatsächlich in meinem Traffic. Also wenn er mehr Daten runtergeladen. Und er fragt, wenn ich jetzt einen Werbeblocker installiere auf dem Handy, wird dann die Werbung trotzdem runtergeladen und dann nicht ausgeführt? Oder ist sozusagen schon, ist die Werbung dann komplett weg im Sinne von, die wird gar nicht erst geladen?
Kommt drauf an. Also manchmal... Also meistens wird sie gar nicht erst runtergeladen. Aber in einigen Fällen, wenn zum Beispiel der Server das Ausliefern des Inhalts davon abhängig macht, ob du die Werbung runtergeladen hast, dann ist dein Werbeblocker so eingestellt, dass es runterlädt und dann vor Ort auf deinem Telefon durch, was ersetzt, was du dann nicht angezeigt bekommst.
Also es kommt dann zu sagen, darauf andre ich die Webseite unterwegs. Die andere Frage ist, was er fragt, ob ein Werbeblocker, ist das eine zusätzliche App, die auch im Hintergrund arbeitet und dann selber wiederum auch Akku verbraucht?
Ja, aber deutliche Größenordnung, wenige. Auf der anderen Seite ist die Frage schon berechtigt. Da läuft halt einmal ein Programm, über dessen Softwarequalität du einfach nix weißt. Also ja, du installierst dir irgendwie noch eine weitere große Angriffsfläche, wo einmal der gesamte Internetverkehr gegen klatschen kann und Leute! Dann auch noch sämtlichen Traffic zu sehen bekommt. Also dann ist das halt nicht Opera, sondern das ist halt ein Stück Software mit uneinschätzbarer Softwarequalität auf deinem Telefon, die du noch zusätzlich installierst.
Okay, das heißt, wenn ich euch jetzt frage, empfehlt man einen Adblocker, würde ich dir sagen, ne, wir können jetzt keinen Adblocker empfehlen, deswegen frage ich lieber, welche Adblocker benutzt ihr denn?
UBlock Origin und für den restlichen Tracker fickt man eigentlich Ghostory weg.
UBlock, ist das Desktop oder Mobil oder beides?
Ich Desktop.
Dito.
Auch nur Desktop.
Und Mobil nehmt ihr keinen Werbeblocker?
Surf ich eigentlich nicht, nee.
Wow, ein Mensch aus dem letzten Jahr.
Ich hab Spiele und mein Chat auf dem Telefon.
Und ihr surft auch nicht mobil?
Soweit es geht nicht.
Eigentlich nur wenige Seiten. Die vorher schon.
Okay, warum seid ihr alle auf UBlock Origin gekommen?
Das sind halt die, lieb gemeint die, die wirklich Hardcore-Spinner. Die meinen das so und die fangen da nicht an, wie andere Werbeblocker dann irgendwann mal sich als Wegelagerer aufzuschwingen und bestimmte Werbung noch durchzulassen für Geld.
Magst du da konkreter werden?
Ja, das würde mich jetzt auch interessieren.
Die Firma AdBlock Plus, die quasi Marktführer in den Werbeblockern ist, die hat dann irgendwann mal, nachdem sie groß genug geworden sind mit Marktanteilen von 25% der Internetbenutzer, wie zumindest Deutschland weit, 25% der Internet angeblich laut der Werbeblocker-Studie. Und nachdem sie groß genug geworden sind, haben sie dann gesagt, na gut, ist ja nun nicht so, dass wir verhindern wollen, dass Leute über Werbung ihre Angebote finanzieren können im Internet. Dann sorgen wir mal dafür, dass wir bestimmte Werbung durchlassen, die wir vorher für gut befunden haben und für einen klitzekleinen Obolus lassen wir das dann noch zu. Nennen die, glaube ich, ethische Werbung, wenn ich da jetzt nicht Dinge durcheinander werfe. Und das ist eigentlich nicht, wofür ich mir einen Werbeblocker installiere. Da will ich allein wegen der Sicherheit, dass die sämtliche Werbung rausfiltern und will dann nicht quasi dem Wegelagerer ausgeliefert sein, dass der dann am Ende doch was durchlässt.
Naja, aber ist es nicht sozusagen, gibt es denn ein Gegenmodell zur Online-Werbung? Also ich meine, die Frage ist tatsächlich nicht unberechtigt.
Es gibt Webseiten, die das explizite Modell haben. Wenn du ein Abo abschließt, also einen monatlichen oder wie auch immer gearteten Obolus zahlst, dann kriegst du ein Login oder kriegst eine andere URL, mit der du unsere Seite besuchst und dann kriegst du denselben Inhalt zu sehen, allerdings komplett werbefrei.
Also bei Forbes zum Beispiel?
Nee, das gibt's. War das nicht bei Google? Also so eine deutsche IT-Seite war das auf jeden Fall, die das angeboten hat.
Aber selbst dann, die Preise sind ja immer da irgendwie sehr hoch. Also weil das Internet funktioniert ja für die meisten Leute nicht so, dass man diese eine Seite hat, wo man hingeht und sagt, okay, dann kriegst du auch 10 Euro im Monat von...
Gut, dass du fragst. Ich hab durch Zufall aus Interesse mal bei den großen Zeitungen rumgefragt, was man eigentlich so üblicherweise für einmal draufkriegen, dann als Werbekunde wert ist.
Also wenn ich sage, wie viel du durch Werbung verdienst, wenn ich mir einen Artikel angucke?
Das ist jetzt gerade eigentlich so der Preis für... Der realistische Preis für so ein Stück Artikel ist ja genau das, was sie gerade an Werbung verdienen, dividiert durch Anzahl der Leute, die da draufgeklickt haben, wenn sie schwarze Zahlen schreiben. Und da gibt es Magazine, die tun das und die sind auch ziemlich offen in dem, was sie sagen. Und was ich jetzt als konservative Zahlen kommunizieren darf, ist irgendwie so unter 10 Cent pro Artikel, mit dem man so anguckt.
Also die verdienen quasi an mir 10 Cent?
Weniger als 10 Cent.
Weniger als 10 Cent, okay. Wir haben ja schon gelernt, dass quasi aber das Geld, was ich ausgeben müsste für denselben Preis, wäre dann nochmal höher.
Das hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ach so, die kriegen ja nur die, also die armen Werbetreiber. Ach so, die kriegen, wenn ich der Zeitung direkt Geld gebe, dann verdienen die Werbetreiber gar nicht.
Genau.
Das heißt, wenn ich der Zeitung direkt 10 Cent pro Artikel geben würde, gibt's dann irgendwie so, wie viel lese ich denn durchschnittlich im Jahr?
Ich hab das geguckt, so bei der Plattform war ich so bei 120 Artikel. Das heißt, als ich es hochgerechnet hab, bin ich für unter 10 Euro rausgekommen. Jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr wie genau, aber das war so ein Jahresabo für irgendwie sämtliche Artikel, die mich da interessiert haben, wäre irgendwie bei knapp 10 Euro rausgekommen. Und das wär ich irgendwie spielend auch bereit, da zu bezahlen, um dann...
Das ist interessant, das würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren, ob Leute... Also, wir haben jetzt eine 2 Stunden drüber gesprochen, und dann überlegt man sich das so, und dann sagt man, ja, okay, so 10 Euro im Jahr, das wär schon ganz geil. Wenn man es hochgerechnet sagt, okay, 100 Euro im Jahr, und dann sozusagen alle News-Seiten, die ich lese, sind dann...
Das ist lustig, dass du diese Zahl sagst, weil am Ende bleibt diese Kohle immer bei nur bestimmten Anbietern hängen. So was wie Google, die damit... 60 Prozent, jetzt will ich nicht lügen. War eine große Zahl. Über 50 Prozent bleibt da hängen. Und denen ist ein User 100 Dollar wert im Jahr. Das ist so die Größenordnung, was die damit einsacken. Das heißt, für sämtliche... Lassen sie mal, wenn es 50 Prozent sind, dann lass es so ein User 200 US-Dollar pro Jahr, was da an Werbung reinkommt, sein. Und für den Preis sollte man sich eigentlich freikaufen dürfen. Fänd ich jetzt. Und so wär's mir eigentlich auch, glaub ich, auch wert.
Und das Interessante ist auf Seiten, es gibt ja jetzt auch Bestrebungen der Verleger, über eine quasi zentrale Plattform Artikel einzeln bezahlen zu lassen. Und was halt auffällt, gerade wo Erdgeist diese Zahlen genannt hat, ist eigentlich, dass ein Artikel bei diesen Portalen einfach mal eine ganze Größenordnung teurer ist. Also da reden wir halt nicht irgendwie von 10, 20 Cent, sondern von 75 bis 2 Euro. Und das ist halt mal eine ganz andere Nummer. Und wenn ich mir überlege, klar, so eine Zeitung, wenn ich die lese, das kriegt man immer vorgebetet von den Verlegern, das ist eine Mischkalkulation. Und wenn man jetzt den einen Artikel kauft, dann liest man aber die ganzen Anzeigen nicht. Und deswegen müsste der teurer sein. Aber es ist trotzdem spannend zu sehen, dass da offensichtlich noch eine ganze Menge Unterschied ist zwischen dem Preis, der real ist, wo ja offensichtlich die Medienhäuser sich auch finanzieren können. Und dem Preis, der da auf diesen Portalen abgerufen wird, für einzelne Artikel.
Ich würde mich, was mir jetzt natürlich interessieren würde, ist sozusagen jemand, der die Sendung gehört hat, und jetzt sozusagen über die Auswirkungen von anderen Werbung Bescheid ist, Bescheid weiß, ob er jetzt sagen würde, ok, 100 Euro im Jahr oder sagen wir 10 Euro im Jahr für dieses eine Zeitungsangebot, was ich wirklich gerne mag, wären schon ok für mich. Weil es ist ja ganz oft so, dass ein Bewusstsein dafür, dass es eigentlich eine gute Idee ist, Geld für Dinge zu bezahlen, häufig nicht da ist. Also ich finde, man sieht das immer ganz deutlich im App Store, wo die ganzen kostenlosen Spiele total beliebt sind, aber halt totaler Crap, aber die Leute einfach sich nicht durchregen können, Geld zu bezahlen. Also falls ihr da gerade draußen sitzt und sagt, ja irgendwie 10 Euro, fände ich eine gute Idee, dann könnt ihr gerne noch mal kurz anrufen, 0371 77 97 110 und Bescheid sagen, ob euch das überzeugen würde oder vielleicht auch nicht, wenn ihr sagt so, nee, trotzdem Werbung.
Hab ja noch einen. Du hast ja den...
Leute!
Was die Hörer ja immer nicht sehen ist, wie Markus da einfach in seinem Stuhl zusammensackt und sich die Hand über dem Kopf zusammenschlägt.
Doch, das kann man sehen unter Streaming...
Streaming Media CCCDE.
Gibt das Ganze auch als HD Video Livestream.
Genau, aber wir haben ja noch ein Faktor komplett außen vor gelassen, der in dieser ganzen Online-Werbung auch immer noch grad massiv in die Gesellschaft eingreift. Weißt du, draußen auf der Straße ist ja nicht so, dass man eigentlich so an Billboards, an Werbewänden vorbeifährt und sich da nicht von erretten kann. Da gibt's ja eine physikalische Grenze, was man dann wie zuflastern kann mit Werbung. Aber wenn du dich grad durchs Internet bewegst, dann ist es irgendwie nie mit dem, dass du diese Bande runterladen musst, ist ja in einer Ökonomie, die davon lebt, dass Leute Aufmerksamkeit bestimmten Dingen widmen können, ist das Verbrennen von Aufmerksamkeit von Leuten ja irgendwie auch ein Faktor für die Volkswirtschaft. Das heißt, das Nächste, was ich gefunden hab, war so eine größere Studie darüber, wie soziale Medien und irgendwie die abgelenkten Mitarbeiter und Firmen gerade, dass die 500 Milliarden Euro Schäden durch Ablenkung am Arbeitsplatz gerade verursachen. Das heißt, das ist so eine Größenordnung, die alles, was so an Aufmerksamkeit in Online-Werbung reinsteckt, kannst du dann nicht mehr in andere Dinge machen. Du kannst dich dann nicht mehr aktiv beteiligen, du kannst keine Inhalte produzieren, du bist dann halt wie für die zusätzlichen paar Minuten, die du irgendwie diese Pop-ups da wegklicken musst, wo du mit dieser Werbung konfrontiert bist, bist du abgelenkt und kannst dann, deine Aufmerksamkeit wird halt für die paar Cent, die die da wirklich verdienen, werden riesige Schäden angerichtet eigentlich in der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie.
Ich wollte das nicht so spontan widersprechen und sagen, das ist doch Quatsch, die Werbung ist doch eh keiner mehr, es ist wie Spam-Mail, sie sortiert man weg. Aber du brauchst ja trotzdem diesen kleinen Moment, wo du die Spam-Mail wegsortierst oder das Werbebander wegklickst und der kostet natürlich Zeit. Interessant.
Ich wollte bloß gerade anmerken, du hast gerade 500 Milliarden gesagt. Früher in der Sendung hast du eine andere Zahl genannt, da waren es 40 Milliarden, das war das, was die Werbeindustrie bringt. Kleines Missverhältnis.
Aber die 500 Milliarden beziehen sich auf Ablenkung durch soziale Medien.
Also du verdienst halt 40 Milliarden dadurch, dass du 500 Milliarden Schaden machst.
Moment, die Zahlen sind halt nicht direkt vergleichbar, weil das eine die Ablenkung durch Facebook und Konsorten ist, aber das war die einzige Zahl, die ich wirklich dazu gefunden habe, weil sich einfach niemand bisher die Mühe gemacht hat, das ernsthaft zu erforschen.
Wie groß der Schaden von Werbung ist.
Wie groß der Schaden dann am Ende von Werbung ist und vor allem, so dass...
Super.
Leute, wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch haben? Wir haben jetzt noch zwei Anrufer. Der eine will zahlen, der andere nicht. Das hören wir uns noch kurz an. So, Lennart aus Mitte, 18 Jahre. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich würde grundsätzlich zahlen, wenn ich als Schüler mich immer mehr Geld hätte als mein liebliches Faschengeld. Ich habe keine Ahnung, 30 bis 50 Euro für die meisten deutschen Zeitungen, damit ich da nicht meine 10 Cent pro...
Okay, also du würdest sagen, im Jahr 30 bis 50 Euro und dann sozusagen alle großen Zeitungen in Deutschland lesen, um dir die Werbung zu ersparen? Und war das schon immer deine Meinung, oder hast du gerade die Sendung gehört und denkst jetzt, okay, das wäre vielleicht die bessere Idee?
Das war schon so, seitdem ich mir das erste Mal drüber ernsthaft Gedanken gemacht habe, als ich über Pefe auf Maxim geworden bin.
Lennart, vielen Dank. So, und dann haben wir den David aus Karlshaus. Der will doch noch lieber Werbung kommen. Hallo, David. Hast du die Sendung gehört?
Ja, ist erst gerade eingestartet vor vier Stunden ungefähr. Und genau, die ganzen Fürsprechungen für den Adblocker gehört. Ich selbst bin ein bisschen skeptisch. Also mich stört ehrlich gesagt persönlich die Werbung jetzt nicht so. Und ich bin auch eher der Meinung, also ich bin jetzt nicht bereit, da so viel zu bezahlen. Dafür schaue ich mir die Werbung eher an. Und wie gesagt, ich nehme es jetzt auch nicht so als störend wahr. Und sehe auch eher, dass dadurch, dass jetzt immer mehr Adblocker genutzt werden, sehe ich eher die Gefahr, dass immer mehr Inhalte auch schon kostenflüssig, flüchtig werden im Netz. Und das sehe ich halt eher kritisch.
Aber hast du auch den Teil in der Sendung gehört, wo erklärt wurde, dass Werbung auch ein Sicherheitsrisiko ist?
Ja, das habe ich auch noch kurz mitbekommen.
Okay, aber das ist dir dann egal oder nimmst du in Kauf?
Ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich arbeite auch im Online-Marketing-Bereich.
Du musst das quasi gut finden.
Ja, ich arbeite bei einer Agentur.
Also du entwirfst diese Werbung?
Ja, genau. Auch.
Und da hast du die, also findest du... Na ja, du musst jetzt immer was immer sein müssen.
Jetzt nicht so, dass ich alles gute essen muss, aber ich sehe das halt so aus dem anderen Sicht noch. Deswegen muss ich kurz anrufen und ich hab das so ein bisschen.
Was ist denn in deinen Augen gute Online-Werbung? Es gibt ja Online-Werbungen, wo man wirklich sagen muss, es geht überhaupt gar nicht, das ist laut, das ist störend. Was ist denn in deinen Augen eine gute Online-Werbung?
Na ja, natürlich sollte die halt zielgerichtet sein. Und es gibt ja auch solche, wo der User nach bestimmten Inhalten sucht und die dann durch Werbung findet. Das finde ich zum Beispiel weniger störend. Also klar, so Pop-up-Geschichten. Viele finden natürlich auch so eine Verfolgung durchs Netz dann schwierig. Ja, klar, ich kann nicht das voll verstehen auf der anderen Seite, aber ich finde halt so ein bisschen auch, mir hat jetzt so ein bisschen die Haltung halt gefehlt, dass wie gesagt immer mehr Inhalte halt kostenpflichtig werden, gerade bei Zeitschriften, wo man dann halt viele Inhalte nicht sehen kann.
Vielleicht wäre das ja eine gute Sache.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also prinzipiell, für mich damit ist nichts verkehrt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass alle, die Adblocker halt nutzen, wirklich bereit sind, auch dann entsprechende Beträge zu zahlen. Also das ist glaube ich ein Bruchteil.
Das ist ja genau das Problem, das wissen wir nicht, weil momentan sind die Preise halt noch so hoch, dass man sagt, das ist mir halt zu teuer, wenn ich 10 Euro pro Monat pro Zeitung zahlen muss. Ich finde es halt wirklich interessant, was dann wäre. Es tut mir leid, dass dann eine Branche arbeitslos würde, wenn das funktionier. Aber als Experiment finde ich es zumindest interessant.
Also ich kenne es nur ganz kurz von Seiten in den USA, die also komplett auf Bezahlmodus gegangen sind. Bei denen sind natürlich die Besucherzahlen massiv eingebrochen. Das hat denen aber deswegen nicht so wirklich wehgetan, weil das, was sie an Abonnenten hatten, plötzlich für sie komplett viel besser funktioniert hat. Also im Gesamtergebnis viel besser funktioniert hat, als wenn sie die vielen Seiten haben, an denen sie die ganzen Inhalte und die ganze Werbung auch ausliefern müssen.
Aber dann, okay, ich will mich kurz von David verfehlen, weil die Sendung gleich, okay sag noch ganz kurz.
Nee, ich meine es funktioniert ja auch nur zum Beispiel für solche Seiten. Es gibt ja auch einen Großteil an Werbung, der halt sich nicht so finanzieren kann, wo du keine Abos abschließen kannst, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass man eben gefunden wird im Netz.
Ja, genau, also komme ich gleich noch, dass es noch eine weitere Dimension hat. David, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank erstmal und tschüss, viel Spaß noch. Und genau, was ich sagen wollte ist, ich habe auch genau dieses Ding gelesen, es gibt eine Seite, die hat jetzt nur noch, keine Ahnung, ein paar tausend Kunden oder sowas, verdient dadurch aber mehr als mit Onlinewerbung. Also für die Seite ist es geil. Das Problem ist, dann hat man natürlich die gesellschaftliche Dimension, dass es diese Seiten gibt, die sich finanzieren, denen es gut geht, dass aber Menschen von Zugang zu den Inhalten ausgeschlossen werden. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie löst man das? Oh mein Gott!
War doch bisher auch so, wer sich die Zeitung am Kiosk nicht koffen konnte, der war halt dann erstmal ausgeschlossen.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen keine gute Sache. Das Schöne am Internet war ja gerade, dass wirklich jeder Zugang zu wissen hat, ohne sich leisten können zu müssen.
Pfff, das ist mir jetzt wieder in Sachen so radikal.
Entschuldigung, ich sehe doch die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club Freier Zugang zum Wissen noch mal.
Ja, es gibt irgendwie die Wikipedia, wo Leute gesagt haben, wollen was und es gibt Leute, die Inhalte anbieten und sagen, da will ich Geld für, dass es irgendwie erstmal, oder erstmal Geld haben, dass es jemand konsumiert und diese Modelle haben ja funktioniert lange.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen hochtrabend, aber mir wäre es zum Beispiel irgendwie wichtiger, dass ich kostenlosen Zugriff auf Sachen habe, für die ich auch irgendwie Steuergelder bezahlt habe, wie irgendwie wissenschaftliche Pape war, die jetzt hinter Paywalls verschwinden. Aber ich finde jetzt eher nicht, dass es wichtig ist. Genau, aber ich finde es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so bombend wichtig für die für meine Bildung und für die Menschheit an sich, dass ich jetzt irgendwie kostenlos an Sportergebnisse komme. Sehe ich einfach nicht.
Ja, also ich glaube, jetzt wird es gerade so sagen sehr beschönigend, weil ich glaube, da muss man sich wirklich Gedanken drum machen.
Es ist eigentlich so einfach. Nein, natürlich nicht.
Wenn man eine Paywall einzieht, dann hat das sozusagen schon Konsequenzen. Aber die Sendung ist vorbei. Was ich gelernt habe, ist, Online Werbung ist momentan keine so gute Sache. Ich möchte gerne einen Adblocker benutzen. Habt ihr noch etwas zu verkünden? Chaos Computer Club mäßig?
Überraschend gibt es zum Ende des Jahres ein Kongress.
Ach, verrückt. Jetzt schon.
Gerade jetzt läuft die GPN, die Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht in Karlsruhe und wer sich da die Vorträge angucken möchte, kann, wenn er hier den Stream zu Ende geguckt hat, auf media.ccc.de, sich die restlichen Vorträge angucken und die, die ihr verpasst habt, die könnt ihr als fertige Vortragsvideos bereits angucken unter media.ccc.de.
Sehr schön. Dann bedanke ich bei allen Teilnehmern, Stefan und THS, die nicht mehr dabei sind, Erdgas, Danimo und Henrik, die im Studio waren. Vielen Dank. Sehr gerne. Gerne, gerne. Was wird denn da gelacht? Raus jetzt. Hier kommt jetzt nämlich Flo Heil, er wird euch den Rest der Nacht mit Punk-Musik erfreuen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss!